Andrew Huberman: Welcome to the Huberman
Lab podcast, where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday life.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm Andrew Huberman, and I'm a professor
of neurobiology and ophthalmology
at Stanford School of Medicine.
Today we're discussing water.
Now, to some of you, water might seem
like a boring topic, but I assure you
that water is anything but a boring topic.
In fact, water as a substance is
incredibly interesting for a variety
of reasons that I'll explain today.
In fact, we are going to discuss the
physics and chemistry of water, and
I promise to make it accessible to
anyone and everyone regardless of
whether or not you have a physics
or chemistry background, and I will
discuss how your body needs and
utilizes water depending on what type
of water you drink, the temperature of
that water, when you drink the water,
and indeed how you drink that water.
Now, water is actually a
pretty controversial topic.
In fact, in preparing for this episode,
which took me several months, in
fact, I ran into highly contradictory
information and had to go on some real
deep dives in order to ferret out the
best and most accurate knowledge for you.
I also found that there are generally
two camps of people out there
in terms of how they think about
water and the consumption of water.
One camp generally speaking, is of the
mind that tap water is completely safe.
Perhaps it needs a little bit of
filtering, but that in most areas
of the world, if it runs out of the
tap, and unless there's a warning
sign directly above the faucet,
that you can drink the tap water.
The other camp seems to be the camp
that does not trust anything that comes
out of the tap and is excited by and
in fact, relies on things like reverse
osmosis, deuterium depleted, hydrogen
rich, or other forms of water that
sometimes can be very expensive or at
least involve some substantial steps
in order to clean, filter, alter the
chemistry of, or in some other way, adjust
before they are willing to consume it.
So today what we're going to try and do is
to address all the stances around water.
For instance, we will discuss whether
or not tap water is indeed safe, and I
will give you some tools that will allow
you to address whether or not the water
coming out of your tap is safe, as well
as some tools that will allow you to
address how to clean that water if indeed
it does need filtering and cleaning.
In particular for things like fluorides
and endocrine disruptors, which it turns
out, are quite prominent in a lot, not
all, but a lot of tap water sources.
I will also talk about the more
"esoteric forms of water" that
I mentioned a few minutes ago.
So I will go systematically through
the list of distilled reverse osmosis,
spring water, deuterium depleted
water, high pH water, and for those
of you that are already screaming out
as you hear this, oh no, he's going
to tell us that pH water can alter
the pH of our body in helpful ways.
I'm not going to tell you that, but I will
tell you that the alkalinity or acidity of
the water that is the pH of the water that
you drink has a profound impact on your
ability to absorb and utilize that water
and the impact that those water molecules
have on specific biological systems.
So it turns out pH is very important,
but not for the reasons that you've
probably heard about previously.
I'll talk about how the temperature of
water that you drink does indeed turn
out to be important for the rate of
absorption of that water and its impact
on the cells, tissues, and organs of
your body, and thereby your health.
And I will talk about various zero
cost and low cost tools that you
can use in order to get the most
out of the water that you drink.
And finally, I will talk about when
and how to hydrate your body best.
Before we dive into today's topic,
I wanna share with you some very
interesting results that were just
published on the use of deliberate
cold exposure to benefit fat loss.
Now, deliberate cold exposure is a topic
I've covered before on this podcast.
We have an entire episode about that, that
I've linked in the show note captions.
Deliberate cold exposure can be done
by way of cold showers or immersion
in cold or ice water up to the neck.
That's typically the ways that it's done.
It has been shown to reduce inflammation,
to increase metabolism, and I think some
of the most exciting results that have
been published are the results certainly
in humans showing that deliberate cold
exposure can increase the release of
so-called catecholamines, which are
dopamine, norepinephrine, and epinephrine.
And those increases in those three
molecules are quite long lasting
and lead to substantial increases in
mood and focus throughout the day.
Now, many people out there hear about
deliberate cold exposure and cringe.
Other people hear about it and cringe
because they've heard that deliberate cold
exposure, especially by way of immersion
in water, can block the adaptation
to strength or hypertrophy training.
What I mean by that is yes, indeed there
are data showing that if one gets into
very cold water up to the neck in the six
hours, anytime that is in the six hours
after strength or hypertrophy training,
that some of the strength and hypertrophy
increases that one would observe, are
blocked by that deliberate cold exposure.
However, after six hours does
not seem to be a problem.
So it can be done on other days besides
the strength and hypertrophy training.
It can be done before strength
and hypertrophy training.
It can be done after endurance work.
And I should mention that it does not
appear that cold showers disrupt the
adaptations to strength and hypertrophy
training, even if they're done immediately
after strength or hypertrophy training.
Okay, with that said, many people do enjoy
the effects of deliberate cold exposure,
in particular for those increases in mood
and alertness that are the consequence
of those increases in the catecholamine,
dopamine, norepinephrine, and epinephrine.
And again, those increases
are very long lasting.
So it's not just during
the exposure to cold.
It is for several hours up to
four, maybe even five or six hours,
depending on how cold and how long the
deliberate cold exposure happens to be.
Again, there's a lot to say and
explore about deliberate cold exposure.
So again, I'll just refer you to the
episode on deliberate cold exposure.
If you want to explore the mechanisms
and the positive health outcomes,
some of the controversies within
the data, etc., within that episode.
Meanwhile, I definitely want to
share with you the results of this
recent study that just came out.
The title of this study is "Impact
of Cold Exposure on Life Satisfaction
and Physical Composition of Soldiers".
The reason this study is very interesting
is that it's one of the few studies
that used, or I should say, explored
both deliberate cold exposure by
immersion in cold water, as well as
deliberate cold exposure by way of cold
showers as it relates to weight loss.
Now, there's already data out there on
the effects of deliberate cold exposure
and metabolism, and here I'm mainly
referring to the beautiful work of Dr.
Susanna Søberg and colleagues in
Scandinavia that showed that people that
do 11 minutes total of deliberate cold
exposure by immersion and cold water
up to the neck per week, so 11 minutes
per week total, spread out across some
different sessions by way of getting into
water that's uncomfortably cold up to the
neck, and then getting out and then doing
that several times per week to hit that
11 minutes or more threshold, and, this
is very important, we'll come up in a
moment in the context of this new study,
and warming up not by getting into a warm
shower, which is frankly what I do after
my cold showers or getting into the ice
bath or cold water immersion, but rather
forcing their body to warm up naturally
by using its own metabolic abilities.
In those studies, they observed
substantial increases in brown fat stores,
which are fat stores that you really want
around the heart, and clavicles increases
in metabolism that were quite dramatic
in my opinion, and that could be very
beneficial for allowing people to feel
more comfortable at cold temperatures when
they're not in cold water and on and on.
So lots of benefits shown in that study.
In this study, what I thought was
particularly interesting is, again,
they explored both immersion in
cold water and cold showers, and the
duration of cold exposure that they
found led to substantial fat loss,
especially around the abdomen, was
very brief, deliberate cold exposure.
Let me give you a few
details about this study.
The study involved 49 subjects that
include both males and females.
This is also really important.
The beautiful work of Susanna
Søberg and colleagues, as far
as I know, only looked at males.
This study looked at males and females.
They were 19 to 30 years old, and there
basically were two groups, people who
either were assigned to get deliberate
cold exposure, or they were not
assigned to deliberate cold exposure.
The form of deliberate cold exposure
involved one session per week of cold
immersion in cold water up to the neck.
And to just give you a sense of
how cold it was, it was 3 degrees
Celsius, which translates to
about 37.5 degrees Fahrenheit.
That's pretty darn cold, but
it was only for two minutes.
Okay, so one session at 3 degrees Celsius,
otherwise known as 37.4 degrees Fahrenheit
for two minutes every week, once a week.
In addition, the same subjects did
five cold showers per week, or a
minimum of five cold showers per week.
And those cold showers were
slightly warmer than the
immersion in cold water condition.
So they were 10 degrees Celsius
approximately, or 50 degrees
Fahrenheit, still pretty cold.
And the duration of that cold
water exposure in the shower
was just for 30 seconds.
Okay, so this is interesting to
me because many people don't have
access to cold water immersion.
They might not have an ice bath
or any place they can do that, but
they, most people do have access
to a cold shower of some sort.
Plus, I think most people could
do probably one ice bath per
week or find a place where they
could get into cold water safely.
Now, I should point out that some
people will not do well going
into 37.5 degree Fahrenheit, aka 3
degrees Celsius water, having never
done anything like this before.
So if you're going to try and employ
these sorts of protocols that were used
in the study, I do recommend that you
ease into it over the course of a week
or so and become somewhat adapted to
the, the shock of cold water exposure.
So maybe start at, you know, 50
degrees Fahrenheit, kind of ease
your way back in terms of the
cold water immersion, especially.
Now, another critical feature of
this study is, as with the beautiful
work by Susanna Søberg, the subjects
were told to warm up naturally
after the deliberate cold exposure.
So they basically hung out outside of
the cold water immersion or outside of
the cold shower for 10 minutes after
they were exposed to the cold in their
bathing suit, or I'm, I'm assuming they
were wearing something, but the point is
that you are not going from deliberate
cold exposure directly into a hot shower
or a sauna or something of that sort.
So again, their bodies were forced to heat
up again naturally after the deliberate
cold exposure, but after the 10 minute
period, they were able to do whatever they
wanted, essentially, reclothe, take a warm
shower, and so on and go about their day.
Now the results of this deliberate
cold exposure protocol, again, 2
minutes in cold immersion at 3 degrees
Celsius, 37.5 degrees Fahrenheit,
plus 5 cold showers per week of 2
minutes long, a little bit warmer, 10
degrees Celsius, 50 degrees Fahrenheit.
Now, the deliberate cold exposure
used in this study caused
many different statistically
significant positive changes.
They had a very extensive questionnaire
that related to mood, everything
from levels of anxiety to sexual
satisfaction, and on and on.
In fact, they saw a statistically
significant improvement in sexual
satisfaction in the subjects that were
exposed to deliberate cold exposure.
Not in the control group, although they
didn't look at this, chances are those
improvements in sexual satisfaction
were the downstream consequence of
the known increases in testosterone
and free testosterone that occur
in both men and women who do the
sorts of deliberate cold exposure.
Again, testosterone being an important
hormone for libido in both men and women.
They also saw improvements in regulation
of anxiety, which I think is very
interesting given that the deliberate
cold exposure often causes people anxiety.
But here and in other studies we've
seen it can lead to an better ability
to buffer against anxiety in the
normal happenings of everyday life.
Perhaps the most interesting and
significant results that they found
in the study however, were that in
particular in men, there was a reduction
in waste circumference following 8
weeks of this deliberate cold exposure,
as well as a 5.5% on average, 5.5%
reduction in abdominal fat, that
was quite statistically significant
when compared to the other groups.
Now, why there was no observed reduction
in abdominal fat or waist circumference
in the female subjects isn't clear.
Could have to do with just the
way that body fat is stored and
metabolized in females versus males.
That is going to be a topic
for future exploration.
So I do think the study is very
interesting because when you look at
the landscape of science and discussion
around deliberate cold exposure, I
think there's a general consensus
now that deliberate cold exposure
can change one's sense of mood and
wellbeing through this increases in
catecholamines that I mentioned earlier.
But the impact on metabolism itself has
been somewhat controversial because the
overall changes in metabolism that are
observed while statistically significant
in many studies, have not ever really been
shown to translate into weight loss or
body fat loss in any kind of specific way.
And of course, a great advantage of this
study is that by exploring soldiers,
they were able to really hold constant a
number of other features like the amount
of daily activity that those soldiers
are exposed to, their diet, their living
conditions, and so on and so forth.
So at least insofar as human
studies are done, it's a, it's
a very well controlled study.
We'll provide a link to the
study in the show note captions.
And for those of you that are thinking
about employing the protocol that's
used in this particular paper, or
combining it with existing deliberate
cold exposure protocols, to me it
seems pretty straightforward in
of pretty minimal time investment.
Just 2 minutes of deliberate cold
exposure by way of water immersion
up to the neck, and 5 times a week
of 30 seconds each of deliberate
cold exposure by way of cold shower.
And just a quick mention
about cold showers.
If you're going to use cold showers
to do deliberate cold exposure,
you're going to want to stand
under the shower itself, right?
And essentially have it hit your head,
the back of your neck and your upper
back, which is where most of your
brown fat stores are concentrated.
And it turns out that cold exposure to
those regions of the body in particular,
are going to trigger the adaptation of
increased brown fat stores, which involves
increases in mitochondria in those fat.
Again, this is not the
blubbery fat beneath the skin.
This is the fat that acts as kind of
an oil in the furnace that is your
thermogenic properties of your body to
generate heat and burn off so-called white
adipose tissue elsewhere in the body.
Now, anyone that understands the laws
of physics and thermodynamics will be
saying, wait, in order to get fat loss,
you need to have a caloric deficit.
Calories in, calories out still applies.
And yes, that's absolutely true.
We can only conclude on the basis of the
results of this study that the people that
lost body fat were indeed in a caloric
deficit, presumably because all other
factors were held more or less constant
in this group of soldiers, presumably
because the deliberate cold exposure
itself elevated metabolism, thereby
increasing the calories out component of
the calories in calories out equation,
which of course, governs the rules of
weight loss and body fat loss as well.
Before we begin, I'd like to emphasize
this podcast is separate from my
teaching and research roles at Stanford.
It is, however, part of my desire and
effort to bring zero cost to consumer
information about science and science
related tools to the general public.
In keeping with that theme, I'd like to
thank the sponsors of today's podcast.
Our first sponsor is LMNT.
LMNT is an electrolyte drink with
everything you need and nothing you don't.
That means plenty of salt,
magnesium and potassium, the
so-called electrolytes and no sugar.
Now, salt, magnesium, and potassium
are critical to the function of
all the cells in your body, in
particular to the function of your
nerve cells, also called neurons.
In fact, in order for your neurons
to function properly, all three
electrolytes need to be present in the
proper ratios, and we now know that
even slight reductions in electrolyte
concentrations or dehydration of
the body can lead to deficits in
cognitive and physical performance.
LMNT contains a science backed
electrolyte ratio of 1000 milligrams.
That's one gram of sodium, 200
milligrams of potassium, and
60 milligrams of magnesium.
I typically drink LMNT first thing in
the morning when I wake up in order
to hydrate my body and make sure I
have enough electrolytes and while
I do any kind of physical training
and after physical training as well,
especially if I've been sweating a lot.
If you'd like to try LMNT, you
can go to drinklmnt, that's
lmnt.com/huberman to claim a free
LMNT sample pack with your purchase.
Again, that's drinklmnt.com/huberman.
Today's episode is also
brought to us by Thesis.
Thesis makes custom nootropics.
Now, nootropics is a
word that I don't like.
I don't like it because it means
smart drugs and as a neuroscientist
we know that we have brain circuits
for focus, brain circuits that enable
creativity, brain circuits that
allow task switching and on and on.
So there's really no such thing as
a brain circuit for being smart.
Now, Thesis understands this and has
designed custom nootropics that are
designed to get your brain and body
into the optimal state for the specific
types of work that is physical or
cognitive work that you want to do.
I've been using thesis for more
than a year now, and it's completely
changed the way that I approach work.
I typically take the clarity formula
prior to doing any kind of cognitive
work, and I'll take their energy
formula often before workouts.
If you'd like to try your own personalized
nootropics starter kit, you can go
online to takethesis.com/huberman and
take their brief three minute quiz.
That quiz will allow them to send you
four different trial formulas that
you can use for a month, and then
you can iterate with them to find
the ideal Nootropic formulas for you.
Again, that's takethesis.com/huberman
and use the code huberman at checkout
to get 10% off your first order.
Today's episode is also brought
to us by HVMN Ketone IQ.
Ketone IQ is a ketone supplement
that increases blood ketones.
Now, many people have heard of
the ketogenic diet, and indeed
the ketogenic diet has been
useful for many people out there.
However, most people out there, including
myself, do not follow a ketogenic
diet that is I eat carbohydrates.
However, it's important to note
that even if you are not on a
ketogenic diet, you can benefit
from increasing your blood ketones.
In fact, I'll use Ketone IQ after lunch
or in the afternoon with some coffee or
sometimes first thing in the morning.
If I'm particularly hungry and I
want to do exercise or I want to do
cognitive work, but I want to delay
my first meal using Ketone IQ allows
me to curb my hunger and gives me a
lot of focus and energy, and that's
because ketones are one of the brain's
preferred fuels for cognitive work.
In fact, ketones have been shown to be
associated with four brain function,
which is associated with context switching
focus and formulations of strategies, etc.
All the sorts of things that are
important for doing deliberate
focused work or physical performance.
If you'd like to try Ketone IQ
you can go to hvmn.com/huberman
to save 20% off your order.
Again, that's hvmn.com/huberman.
The huberman Lab podcast is now
partnered with Momentous supplements.
To find the supplements we discuss
on the Huberman Lab podcast, you
can go to livemomentous spelled
O-U-S livemomentous.com/huberman.
And I should just mention that
the library of those supplements
is constantly expanding.
Again, that's livemomentous.com/huberman.
Let's talk about water, and
let's start off by answering
the question, what is water?
Water is of course H₂O, most everybody
knows that from an early age, but what
H₂O means is that each molecule of water
consists of two hydrogens and one oxygen.
Now, the physical arrangement of those
two hydrogens and one oxygen turns out
to be really important for how water
functions in the body, and frankly,
elsewhere in our world and life, if
you were to make a peace symbol, that
is to put up your index finger and
your middle finger simultaneously.
In fact, I'm gonna recommend you do
that now, unless you're using your
hands for something else important.
In which case do it later.
Well, if you make that piece symbol and
you look at your hand, you have a pretty
good impression of what an individual
water molecule consists of, which is
H₂O two hydrogens and an oxygen and,
with that piece symbol, the fingers
or the tips of your fingers rather
are gonna represent the hydrogens.
Your fingers, that is the length of each
of those fingers is going to represent
the electron bonds to the oxygen and the
palm of your hand and the fingers that are
down are going to represent the oxygen.
Okay?
Now, what's important about
that visual impression or visual
image of the individual water
molecule is that it is polarized.
That is the hydrogen's over on one side.
Both of them are over on one side
and the oxygen is over on another.
And what's really important about
water molecules being polarized is
that they can bind to one another
by way of that polarization.
And this has to do with something that
we all kind of learned in chemistry
at one point, but many of us forgot.
Maybe we didn't even understand it
the first time around, which is that
positives and negatives attract.
So when you have individual water
molecules, they have the opportunity
to interact and essentially bind to
one another and they bind through
what are called covalent bonds.
Covalent bonds are relatively weak
bonds, and so as a consequence,
water can change its confirmation.
However, covalent bonds are strong enough
that water actually can maintain some
structure and that structure will vary,
of course, depending on its temperature.
So, what you need to know about
water is that indeed it consists
of lots of individual H₂O , and
those H₂O  can arrange themselves in
different ways, and that temperature
is a strong determinant of the
arrangement of those water molecules.
That is, they're bonding to one another.
And in fact, even they're
spacing between those bonds.
So again, even if you don't have
any chemistry, stay with me because
you'll definitely understand this.
Water can exist in at least
3 forms and maybe 4 forms.
We know that it can be liquid, of course.
That's really what normally what
we think of when we think of water.
It can be gas, so we
think of steam, right?
So if you heat it up, it takes on a  not
a semi-solid or a semi-liquid form, it
takes on this property of steam or gas.
Okay?
So when you see steam or when you
breathe on a cold day through your
mouth or through your nose and you see
your air, those are water molecules
that are condensing, that is bonding
in certain ways, based on differences
in temperature between the inside
of your body and the outside air.
And of course it can be
a solid, it can be ice.
Now, ice is fascinating and important
in understanding how water works, and
this will become relevant later when
we think about how water works within
the body as well, especially how
different temperatures of water impact
the health and behavior of our cells.
And the most important point to understand
about water in its solid state is that
unlike most substances when water is
in its solid state, it is actually less
dense than when it's in its liquid state.
So just think about that.
Most substances, like most metals,
for instance, when they are in a
solid state, they're more dense
than when they're in a liquid state.
So, for instance, if they're in a solid
state, they will sink in a container
filled with their liquid form, not water.
Water is very interesting because
as you cool water and water
transitions from a liquid to a solid.
It still binds.
That is, it can form bonds between those
different molecules of water, but the
spacing between those H₂O , so again,
those peace symbols with hands, so if you
had a bunch of those, so if you had, you
know, a thousand hands all making peace
symbols, they can bond to one another.
But when it's cold, those
bonds are actually made
further apart from one another.
And as a consequence, ice, as
we all know, floats in water.
In other words, put very simply, water
is unusual and special in that, in its
solid form ice, it is actually less
dense than when it's in its liquid form.
And that's why ice floats in water.
Now this is important not just to
our biology, but to all of life.
Because if you think about it, if it were
not the case that water is less dense
in its solid form ice than it is in its
liquid form, the bottoms of our oceans
would be covered with thick sheets of ice.
And if that were the case, you can be
absolutely sure that life would not
exist on our planet the way that it does.
And there's a good chance that we would
not exist as a species because so much
of what allows us to exist on  this
planet and the other animals to exist
on this planet, relies on photosynthesis
pathways in plants that are dependent on
the sun and interactions with the oceans
and lakes and other bodies of water.
And of course, the ice
caps are vitally important.
That is the presence of ice,
especially at the poles.
But elsewhere,  in bodies of water as
well, so-called icebergs are a critical
part of the ecosystem that allows
for everything from photosynthesis
to the ability of certain animals
to extract food from each other
and from their local resources.
Now, there's a whole discussion to be
had there, but the important point for
now is that the physical properties of
the bonds between water that are made and
changed depending on temperature, turn
out to be essential for us to be present
on this planet at all and for our cells
to function in the ways that they do for
sake of health and for sake of disease.
And we'll explore this later when we
talk about the critical relationship
between temperature pH, which is the
relationship between alkalinity, how
basic or acidity, how acid a given
liquid, or in this case we're gonna
be talking about water is and the ways
that our cells can or can't use water.
So I realize that this is fairly in
depth for those of you that don't have
much of a background in chemistry.
I've tried to keep it really top contour,
but if you can make a piece symbol or if
you can just imagine a piece symbol in
your mind and realize that that's a water
molecule and that those water molecules
combine to one another through bonds that
are relatively strong, but weak enough
that they can be broken if they need
to, and that the temperature that those
water molecules are exposed to changes
the distance between those bonds and
that's what allows ice to float in water,
then you are gonna have no problem with
the remainder of the discussion today.
In fact, You will also have the ability
to understand things that you've observed
many times over, but perhaps have never
thought about or really understood,
which are, for instance, that water
has a certain level of surface tension.
For instance, if you've ever been to
the ocean and the waves are coming in,
what you'll notice is if you walk on
the dry sand or gravel,  pebbles that
is of the ocean, it's very easy, right?
I mean, the pebbles move
down or the sand moves down.
It depresses a little bit due
to the weight of your body.
But as you get closer to the water,
you're gonna sink deeper because that
sand is more saturated with water.
But at some point, you won't be able to
actually walk on top of the water, right?
It has been said that
Jesus walked on water.
There's the so-called Jesus Christ
lizard so named because it can
actually walk on the surface of water.
A leaf can float on the surface
of water under some conditions.
A coin can float on the surface of water.
If you make coffee in the morning, you
can actually take a spoonful of that
hot coffee and pour a little bit on
the surface of your coffee, and you'll
notice that it will bead up, and  you'll
get little round spheres of water.
Those are little water molecules bound
to one another that spin on top of
the surface before they sink under.
That has everything to do with
the bonding between water that's
dependent on temperature, but
also as with the difficulty for
essentially everybody, to walk on
water or for animals to walk on water.
The surface tension of water
allows certain things to float
there or to stay at the surface.
But there's a very thin layer of
water molecules at the surface of
water that are more dense than the
water that resides at deeper depths.
And that's why most things,
including us sink in water,
we are more dense than water.
Now, I did mention earlier that
there are 3 forms of water.
Those are the ones that we all
are familiar with, the solid
liquid and gas forms of water.
However, there are data mainly from
Gerald Pollack laboratory at the
University of Washington that have
described the so-called fourth phase
of water, which is structured water.
And we'll get into this a little bit
later because structured water has really
been a prominent topic in the, let's
call it the water health aficionados.
It's a heavily debated topic as
to whether or not structured water
is somehow better for ourselves
if it exists within our bodies.
We'll get into that in full detail later.
But the whole notion of structured
water is that in the presence of
certain solids or certain liquids, the
confirmation of water that is the water
molecules actually change somewhat.
This has been demonstrated.
Whether or not it has relevance
to the biological function of
our body is a different issue.
But we know that there is this fourth
phase of water called structured water.
Structured water is a fairly complicated
topic, but we can make it very simple
for sake of today's discussion.
I mentioned earlier that opposite
polls attract that is positives and
negatives attract, and typically,
things that are negatively charged
when presented with another negative
charge either repel or don't attract.
Things that are positively
charged in the presence of another
positive charge also tend to repel.
This is the basis of magnets,
either sticking to one another
or repelling from one another.
There's also the idea that human
beings who are opposites attract,
but that's a different episode
that we need to do in the future.
The point here is that structured
water is a unique condition in which
the local environment that these
water molecules happen to be in allows
positive charges between different
water molecules to attract one another.
So again, whereas normally it's
positive and negatives that
attract in the configuration
that we call structured water.
Positives and positives attract
and form bonds that are stronger
than the typical bonds that would
be formed between water molecules.
And just as it kind of prelude to our
discussion about structured water,
as it may or may not relate to health
later, there are a number of people that
believe that within the body, because
of the presence of certain liquids
and solids, that the water within our
cells, and in particular within the
interactions with so-called organelles,
organelles are things like mitochondria.
The Golgi apparatus,
they have fancy names.
These are, these are the things
within cells that allow cells to do
everything from make proteins to traffic
proteins out to the surface of cells.
Things like neurotransmitters
and receptors and so on.
A lot of people who are interested
in structured water as it relates to
biological function, have I hypothesized
or like to debate rather whether or not
in the body water is not just present
in its liquid form or gaseous form.
We know it's not present in its
solid form unless you gulp down
some ice cubes, for instance.
But, There is a cohort of people out
there, including some fairly accomplished
scientists that believe that within the
body, the organelles of our cells act as
a substrate for water to exist in this
fourth form, this structured water form.
And that's led to this whole
niche industry of people,  who are
proponents of consuming so-called
structured water, and  again, we'll
get to that a little bit later.
So now you know what individual water
molecules consist of when you hear H₂O
hopefully you'll get that visual image
in your mind of an individual water
molecule being the peace symbol and a
bunch of those binding to one another
through these relatively weak bonds,
but strong enough that certain things
can take place like surface tension.
Keep in mind that surface tension of
water may relate to either standard
bonds between water or this fourth phase.
That's heavily debated still, but we
certainly know that for instance, if
you were to take a piece of wax paper
or glass and you were to pour some
water on it, you would notice that
the water would beat up or kind of
aggregate at particular locations.
When you see that beating up
or the aggregation of water
molecules on a particular
surface, you're seeing two things.
This is actually kind of fun.
The next time you see it, you'll know
that the, the aggregation, the beating
up of water with itself, so individual
water molecules or many water molecules
kind of aggregating at one location
and making a bead of water that's due
to these bonds, these covalent bonds
occurring between water molecules.
Also, you'll notice that on a vertical
pane of glass, say in rain or on your
windshield, that the water will look
almost like it's sticking to the glass.
And that's because there are actually
bonds between the water molecules that
have beat it up themselves and the glass.
So water can not just bind to itself.
It can also bind to certain surfaces.
And the fact that perhaps if you drive
your car, if you were to tap the window,
or if a big enough bead of water formed on
a window that it would start to drip down.
And that's because those bonds with
the surface are strong, but they're
not so strong that it stick at that
location quite different than water
that is in its solid form ice that can
actually really adhere if you've ever
had to scrape ice off a windshield.
So for you, those of you who live in
cold regions, you're familiar with this,
scrape ice off a windshield, you realize
that the bonds between water in its solid
form and different services is quite
a bit stronger than the bonds between
different water molecules with each other.
Or the bonds between water and
different surfaces when they're warmer.
Okay, so I do realize that for a lot
of people listening, that's gonna be
a pretty deep dive into the chemistry
and physical properties of water.
But all you really need to know is that
these water molecules are incredibly
versatile and can bind to each other,
and can bind to different surfaces,
and can allow things to float or to
sink or even to move across surfaces of
water based on the three, perhaps four
different,  states that water can be in.
And that versatility that you observe in
the natural world on window pans and rain
and clouds and hail and ice and snow and
scraping ice off your windshield in the
cold of winter and perspiration and so on.
All of that is fine and good, but
realize that almost all of those same
sorts of properties of water become
extremely relevant when thinking about
how your body actually utilizes water.
And the key thing here is that temperature
and the so-called alkalinity or acidity
that is the pH of water turn out to
be very important determinants of how
water is used by the cells of your body.
In fact, as I'll describe in a moment, we
have entire sets of biological mechanisms
solely devoted to trying to get water into
our cells in very specific ways, including
at specific rates and to use water in
different ways because as you've probably
heard before, we are mostly water.
What's kind of interesting to me and
what I found researching this episode
is that the percentages of our cells
and bodies that are  purported to
be water is a pretty broad range.
Some people say we're 55% water.
Other people will say We're 70% water.
Some people will say We're 95% water.
The exact percentage
doesn't matter so much.
And really just boils down to whether
or not the person that's stating that
percentage is talking about how much
water is present in our cells and body
at a given moment versus how much water
was involved in the process of creating
the sorts of proteins and other things
of our body that are required to have
hair, cell skin cells, brain cells, etc.
So if you really want a number out
there,  I can't give you a single
number if you wanna be accurate,
it's gonna have to be a range.
And basically we are anywhere
from 70% to 90% water depending
on how you define being water.
That is whether or not you're talking
about water being present in cells
in its liquid form or maybe in
this fourth structure water form.
If you're,  of the mind that that
exists within us and whether or not
you're talking about water that was
used to create a given protein, like
a receptor or a neurotransmitter, or
whether or not you're talking about
the water, just being water as H₂O.
Okay, so again, it's very easy to go
down that rabbit hole, and this is
part of the reason why there's such
a wide discrepancy of assertions
as to how much of us is water.
But let's be direct.
Most of our body is water, and there
isn't a single other molecule in the
universe that we can look to and say that
it has as important a role in our health
and biology and frankly, our presence
of life on earth at all than water.
I'd like to take a quick break
and acknowledge one of our
sponsors, Athletic Greens.
Athletic Greens, now called Ag
One is a Vitamin mineral probiotic
drink that covers all of your
foundational nutritional needs.
I've been taking Athletic Greens
since 2012, so I'm delighted that
they're sponsoring the podcast.
The reason I started taking Athletic
Greens, and the reason I still take
Athletic Greens once or usually twice
a day, is that it gets to me the
probiotics that I need for gut health.
Our gut is very important.
It's populated by gut microbiota that
communicate with the brain, the immune
system, and basically all the biological
systems of our body to strongly impact
our immediate and long-term health.
And those probiotics and
athletic greens are optimal and
vital for microbiotic health.
In addition, athletic Greens contains
a number of adaptogens, vitamins
and minerals that make sure that
all of my foundational nutritional
needs are met and it tastes great.
If you'd like to try Athletic Greens, you
can go to athleticgreens.com/huberman and
they'll give you 5 free travel packs that
make it really easy to mix up athletic
greens while you're on the road, in the
car, on the plane, etc., and they'll
give you a year supply of Vitamin D3 K2.
Again, that's athleticgreens.com/huberman
to get the 5 free travel packs and
the year supply of Vitamin D3 K2.
Okay, so now at a minimum, everyone
out there should understand that
water has a particular structure.
So when you hear H₂O, you can kind of
imagine that structure and that the water
molecules can change their confirmation.
That is they can bind to other water
molecules and it turns out they bind
to other things and actually change
the confirmation of other things.
A good example of that is something
we're all familiar with, which is
water's ability to dissolve certain
substances like sugar or salt.
And that is because salt
molecules or sugar molecules
are what we call hydrophilic.
They like water.
And when we say they like water, it just
means that the chemical structure of
salt, sodium, or the chemical structure
of say, sucrose like table sugar, can
actually interact with the hydrogens
and oxygens of water and can change
those salt molecules or sugar molecules,
turning them from solid into liquid.
Essentially creating what are called
solids, which is basically  the dissolving
of solids into liquid solutions.
In fact, water is one of the
best solvents on the planet.
In fact, water is better at
dissolving many solids than is acid.
All right?
That's how incredible water is.
And there are a number of reasons
related to the chemistry of
water that can explain that.
But as we transition from talking about
the physics and chemistry of water to
how water actually behaves within our
body and contributes to our health or
to disease depending on the case, it's
important to understand that molecules
such as sugar and salt can be hydrophilic.
Or as we know, oil and water don't mix.
That's because oil's, lipids
are so-called hydrophobic.
What's hydrophobic?
We'll, just think "Ahh" phobic.
Certain molecules such as lipids
don't dissolve well in water.
And we all intuitively understand
that if you take some olive oil, for
instance, and you put it into a little
glass of water, it'll likely float or
beat up or form little spherical or
amoeba like shapes within the water.
And that's because oil
lipids are hydrophobic.
So different substances out there are
either going to be more hydrophilic.
That is they are going to have a greater
propensity to interact with water and
bind with the different aspects of
the water molecules or hydrophobic to
have less of a propensity to interact
with and bind with water molecules.
And I've sort of been alluding to this
numerous times throughout this podcast
already, the temperature of water and
the pH that is the alkalinity or acidity
of water will have a strong impact
on whether or not a hydrophilic or
hydrophobic substance will have a greater
or lesser tendency to interact with water.
You all know this intuitively as well.
If you've ever tried to dissolve say
a big tablespoon of sugar in very cold
water, you'll notice that the grains don't
dissolve as quickly as when you take that
big tablespoon of sugar and put it into
a warm or hot cup of water, and that's
because the temperature of water actually
changes how well that sugar molecule
is able to change its confirmation
and interact with the water molecules.
Likewise, if you want to get something
that's really hydrophilic into an
aqueous, that is a water containing
solution, the temperature is also
going to strongly impact that.
Now, there are a near infinite
number of examples of how temperature
in pH impact the tendency of
hydrophilic and hydrophobic substances
to dissolve in water or not.
We're not gonna go into all those details,
but as we migrate from our discussion
about the physics and chemistry of water
into how water behaves within our body,
which is what we're gonna do now, and then
as we continue into the third part of our
discussion, which is why and how certain
types of water that some of you are
familiar with, like different pH water,
distilled water, reverse osmosis water,
why those different types of water are
thought to and in some cases do in fact
change the ways that our cells function,
for better or for worse, all of that will
come together and make sense for you.
Okay?
So all the cells of your body, every cell,
even your bones, that is the osteoblasts
and the other cells within your bones,
your bone marrow, your red blood cells,
your white blood cells, your neurons,
your nerve cells, your liver cells, your
kidney cells, all of them require water.
In order to get the proper amount of water
into those cells, there are basically two
ways that water can access those cells.
Now, if we zoom out for a second
and ask ourselves, how does
water actually get into the body?
Most of us just think, oh, well,
we drink that water into our body.
Of course, that's the main way we
can also breathe water molecules
into our body through humid air.
When you hydrate your cells, that is when
you're bringing water into your cells,
that water needs to move from your gut and
into the bloodstream and eventually into
the individual cells, whatever cell type
that may be, and they're basically two
ways that water can access those cells.
The first way has been known
about for a very long time, and
that is so-called diffusion.
Now, the outside of most cells
is made up of fatty stuff, lipid.
So for instance, neurons, nerve
cells have a lipid bilayer.
It's two layers of fat, and you already
know that fat lipid is very hydrophobic.
Okay?
Now that turns out to be not a
problem, but a solution for how water
can get across that lipid barrier.
Why?
It is the fact that water can change its
confirmation and lipids can change their
confirmation just enough so that the
bonds between water and the bonds between
those hydrophobic lipids can interact,
allowing the water molecule to basically
pass through the lipid because it can
bond very weakly or in some cases, not at
all, but very weakly to those lipids and
then be pushed through to the other side.
Really incredible.
If you think about it, if there was too
much of a hydrophobic relationship between
the lipid and the water, the water would
come up to the surface of that fatty
outside  of our cells, and then would
be repelled away from it, or it would
just stay there right at the surface.
And that would be no good because
we actually need that water to
diffuse across the cell membranes, or
actually it's a double cell membrane,
as I mentioned before, two layers.
So water and lipids of cells can
interact with just enough affinity
that the water molecule can diffuse
across those cell membrane barriers.
But, and this is an important but, the
diffusion of water molecules across
those lipid barriers on the outsides of
cells is a fairly slow process compared
to the other way that water accesses
cells and this other way that water
accesses cells is really something that
was just discovered about 10 years ago.
So this is a fairly recent discovery,
but turns out to be a fundamental
discovery, which is the presence
of water called aquaporin channels.
Aquaporin channels are basically portals
through the membrane that allow water
molecules to move very quickly across cell
membranes at a rate of about 1 million
H₂O, 1 million water molecules per second.
And the way that water molecules move
across the cell membrane through those
aquaporin channels is very interesting.
The inside of those channels,
and the way you think of these
is they're literally tubes stuck
through the membranes of cells.
The insides of those channels are
very hydrophobic, allowing those
water molecules to just jot really
quickly and almost as if in your
mind, you can just imagine as if it
was sort of lubricated for the water.
Although it's not really lubricated,
the the water molecules can move through
in single file a million per second.
Now, why would you need two ways for
water to get across cell membranes?
One fairly slow through  basic diffusion,
and again, diffusion folks is the movement
of things from a gradient of higher
concentration to lower concentration,
which you just think about this as
things tend to run downhill from higher
concentration to lower concentration.
They try and create
equilibrium  across space.
So, you know, if you had a bunch
of marbles on one side  of a box,
they're just imagine that these
were water molecules because of the
charges between those hydrogens and
oxygens, there's a tendency for those
marbles to spread out and essentially
take on a fairly even confirmation.
That's basically just
diffusion across a space.
Water molecules will also move
from higher concentration to lower
concentration cross cell membranes,
and then you have these portals, these
tubes or these channels as they're
called, these aquaporin channels where
water molecules can move very quickly.
Now, the reason why biology seems to
have created these aquaporin channels,
and again, I wasn't consulted the design
phase, but the most logical explanation
is that we have many tissues within our
body that often need water very quickly
or need to release water very quickly.
Let's think about a couple of these
and then let's look at what the
actual distribution of aquaporin
channels is throughout the body.
What is an area of your body that
on occasion will need to move
water very quickly out of it?
You can use your imagination here, but
I'll just tell you that for instance,
your tear glands or tear ducts
need to release tears very quickly.
So you need to take water that's stored
in your body if there's an emotional
experience or if you look at a very bright
light, for instance or you know, God
forbid if you get some sort of irritant in
your eye, you're gonna start to tear up.
And those tears are the release
of fluid from those tear ducts.
And so it's gonna be the very rapid
release of water from those tear ducts
through so-called aquaporin channels.
And in fact, aquaporin
channels are heavily expressed.
There are many of them in the
cells of the so-called lacrimal
glands that release tears.
In addition, we need to
absorb water from the gut.
And the gut has a lining, endothelial
lining and other cell lining and
mucosal lining and water needs
often to move very quickly from our
stomach into the rest of the body.
And one way that is accomplished
is through aquaporin channels that
are expressed all along your gut.
So, the discovery of these aquaporin
channels is really highly significant
in terms of understanding the different
ways that water can interact with
and get into the cells of your body.
Now, there are aquaporin channels,
not just in the lacrimal glands that
allow for tearing or within the gut,
but in many tissues within your body.
And there even have different
distributions within those tissues.
In fact, as one looks at the
expression of the different aquaporin
channels, cause it turns out
there are different forms of them.
Across all the cells
and tissues of the body.
There's really no single tissue
within the body, except perhaps
the bones of your body and perhaps
the ligaments to some extent, that
don't have these aquaporin channels.
Some of you out there may have
heard of the so-called fascia,
fascia and sheath muscles.
They're unique kind of connective
tissue that gives some pliability
and yet some rigidity that allow
for a lot of the physical abilities
of your musculoskeletal system.
It's incredible tissue.
We'll do an entire episode
about fascia at some point.
Fascinating, fascinating tissue fascia,
even contained aquaporin channels.
So the role of aquaporin channels
in fascia probably relates to
our specific needs to be able
to use specific muscle groups in
particular ways at particular times.
In other words, if you're sleeping
or lying down or sitting, you're not
using your musculoskeletal system
as much as if you're running or
performing some repetitive behavior.
It turns out that the aquaporin channels
in certain tissues, like the fascia
can be used when we transition from
low mobility states to high mobility
states, allowing more perfusion
or access of water into particular
cells of the body when we need it.
Such as fascinating, fascinating channels.
These aquaporin channels, and again,
only discovered fairly recently,
so we're still learning new things
about our biology all the time.
Now, in a very important feature of
the Aquaporin channel is that the
movement of water molecules across the
cell membrane through those aquaporin
channels is strongly dependent on the
temperature of water and the pH of water.
This becomes especially important in
our description and our deep dive into
so-called alkaline water or higher
pH water a little bit later, but I'll
just give you a little teaser for
now because I'm sure that a number of
people are, are wondering about this.
If you go into the store or even a
convenient store, you will see pH water.
Now, every water has a pH, right?
Lower numbers mean more acidic.
Higher numbers mean more
alkaline, or more basic.
You'll see pH water.
That is 7.4.
You'll see 7.8, you'll see 9.8.
You'll see a huge range of these things,
and there are many, many different claims
about how the pH of water is important
for regulating the pH of the body.
Here's the real story.
The pH of your body, that is
the pH of the cells at different
locations in your body, is strongly,
strongly homeostatically regulated.
What do I mean by that?
It means it doesn't change that much,
which means that you have very specific
biological mechanisms that ensure the
pH is maintained, for instance, in the
skin cells of your skin, in the retinal
cells of your eye, in your brain cells.
Now, It is true that across the
body, different cells and tissues
have fairly widely varying pH.
You know, it has been said that
the pH of bodily tissues is
generally between 7.2 and 7.4.
However, if you were to look at the
pH of your gut, and keep in mind that
your gut is not just your stomach, your
gut is the entire pathway ranging from
your throat all the way down to where
you excrete things out of your body.
That entire pathway has different
pH levels depending on where you are
along the gut and intestinal pathway.
And in fact, having much lower that
is more acidic pH at certain locations
along your gut pathway is what allows
those gut microbiota, those little
microorganisms of which you have trillions
that are important for regulating
everything from neurotransmitter
production to hormone production that
allow them to flourish and do well.
That said, except under conditions of
hemorrhage or changes in blood volume
that are of a dangerous level that can
lead to seizure or even death, the pH
of the rest of the cells of your body,
and also those gut cells doesn't change
that much on a moment to moment basis.
So if somebody tells you that you
should drink alkaline water or alkalized
water as it's sometimes called, In
order to keep your body more alkaline
and less acidic, there is essentially
no basis for that at a macroscopic
level or even at a local level.
Now, what that does not mean is
that the pH of the water that
you drink is not important.
In fact, if the pH of the water that
you drink is too low, that is if the
water that you consume is too acidic,
it will not move as quickly from your
gut into the other regions of your
body, and therefore, the other cells of
your body that require that water will
not be able to access it as readily.
You've probably experienced this if you've
consumed certain water and it feels like
it's sloshing around in your stomach or
it feels like it's just somehow staying
there, or you feel it, its presence
more, not just as volume, but it's almost
as if you can feel the little waves
of water along the inside of your gut.
Now, sometimes that can relate to
temperature, but oftentimes that
can relate to the pH of that water,
and it turns out it is true that
water that is more alkaline, that is
pHs of 7.4 or higher can move more
readily across the Aquaporin channel.
And in terms of absorption of water
from the endothelial lining and
the other cell type lining of your
gut into the rest of your body.
It is true that higher pH water provided
that pH isn't too high, is going to be
absorbed more quickly, which partially
explains why some people have an
affinity for this higher pH water.
Now, this is not to say that you
need to consume high pH water in
order to hydrate your body properly.
I want to be very clear about that.
However, if you are interested
in what the value of elevated pH
water is, it largely has to do
with this accelerated absorption.
And as we'll talk about a little bit
later, there is also growing evidence
that it can adjust the function of
certain cells that are within your
immune system and thereby reduce
certain inflammatory responses.
So I realize as I'm saying this, some
people out there will probably think, oh
no, this guy's like a pH water proponent.
He's saying we have to drink alkaline
water or buy very fancy water.
Now, I want to be clear that is not
what I'm saying, and I'm also not saying
that you need to purchase very expensive
water in order to derive the maximum
benefits from the water that you drank.
It turns out there are a few things that
you can do by way of temperature and by
way of filtering water and a few other
tricks that I'll tell you a little bit
later that will allow you to increase
the absorption rate of water in the gut,
which turns out to be a very interesting,
but also potentially important thing to
do for not just reducing inflammation,
but also making sure that you're getting
proper hydration of different cell types
in your body, including rapid hydration
of your brain cells, which as we'll
also talk about in a few moments, can
greatly enhance cognitive function.
Okay, so we've talked about
how water can get into cells.
There are two ways, diffusion and
movement through these aquaporin channels.
We've earmarked the discussion that
the temperature and the pH of water,
that is the confirmation of water.
And here I really want to embed this in
people's minds, that when we talk about
temperature of water and pH of water,
we're really talking about the arrangement
of those H₂O, those water molecules.
So keep that in mind.
We've covered how water can get
into cells through those two
different ways, diffusion and
through the aquaporin channels.
What we haven't talked about is what
happens to water once it's in cells,
and this is very simple to explain.
Once water is inside of cells, it's
going to be incorporated into the
different proteins and organelles.
Again, organelles are things like
mitochondria, the nucleus of the cells,
which is contained to the DNA and so
forth in different ways, depending
on which proteins are there and how
hydrophilic or hydrophobic those
proteins are, or in some case aren't.
That's an entire landscape of  protein
to water specific interactions, none of
which we need to go into in any specific
detail now, but the one thing that we do
need to realize and keep in mind as we
go forward is that many of the biological
processes in our body that involve the
movement to molecules such as water and
interactions with proteins, are going to
involve the bonding or lack of bonding
between water molecules and proteins.
And anytime we're talking about bonding
of one thing to the next at the level
of chemistry or biology for that matter,
because they're really the same thing.
We're talking about whether or not
there are electrons present or whether
or not there are charges that are
opposite or the same and on and on.
If you've ever heard of so-called
reactive oxygen species, what are
ROS or reactive oxygen species or
so-called free radicals or antioxidants?
All of that is really just
describing the presence or absence
of charges that are bound or unbound.
So for instance, if you hear about free
radicals, sounds pretty wild, right?
Free radicals.
What are free radicals?
Free radicals can damage cells.
They don't always damage cells, but
they can damage cells because they
are essentially free electrons.
They are a charge that's sitting
out there not bound to anything
and therefore can interact with
the molecular structure of certain
proteins and change those structures
by binding to them or interfering with
the normal binding processes of those
proteins to water or to other things.
And in that way cause damage to those
proteins and potentially damage to cells.
Now fortunately, our cells have ways
to deal with those free radicals,
and those are called antioxidants.
Antioxidants are molecules that
can arrive in different forms.
Sometimes we think of antioxidants as
vitamins, but they are also present in
other things as well that essentially
bind up those free radicals or repair the
bonds between cells so that the proteins
are no longer undergoing these, let's
just call them bad confirmations, that
damage the functioning of our cells.
So there are many different
theories of aging.
There are many different theories of
disease, but there is not a single
disease, either of brain or body that
doesn't in some way involve the generation
of what are called reactive oxygen
species, these free radicals and the
damaging of cells at the level of their
individual organelles and so forth.
Nor is there a single disease of brain or
body that has not been shown to benefit
from having some antioxidant interference
get in the way of that oxidative process.
So I realize today is pretty
thick with nomenclature.
For those of you that haven't
already realized it, what you're
learning here is organic chemistry.
So you can feel pretty good about the
fact that if you can understand the water
molecule and understand a little bit about
what free electron is, which is basically
a charge that's out there that can
potentially do damage and the interactions
of things like reactive oxygen species
and the ability of, of stable bonds to
buffer against  or repair certain damage
to cells as we're describing it here.
Well then what you're essentially
thinking about and what we're
talking about is organic chemistry.
Now, since this is a discussion about
chemistry as a service to try and
understand the biological effects of
water, keep in mind that water itself,
believe it or not, can act as an
antioxidant, provided that it's bonding to
things in the proper way, which requires
that it get into cells in the proper
amounts and rates, which requires that
the temperature and pH of that water be
correct and provided that there's enough
water there and that that water isn't
bound to other things, it's not containing
salutes that are damaging and potentially
that it's carrying some of the good things
such as sodium or that there's potassium
present again, the so-called electrolytes
that allow cells to function well.
Okay, so that's a bit of a trench of
information, and I don't want people
to get overwhelmed or confused.
What I'm trying to do here is paint
a picture of the biology of water,
understanding that when you ingest
water, drinking it down, or when you
breathe water vapors in the steam
room or on a humid day, that water is
entering your system, it's accessing
your cells through these two mechanisms,
diffusion across cell membranes or
movement through aquaporin channels.
And then once inside those cells,
it's able to interact with and
change the confirmation of different
proteins and accelerate or slow
down different cellular reactions.
Everything from normal metabolism to
blood pressure to damaged cells, depending
on a number of different features of
that water, as well as what the cells
happen to be doing at any given moment.
So with that in mind, I'd like to turn our
attention to how water, depending on its
temperature, its pH, how much we drink,
or how little we drink when we drink
that water, etc., how that can impact the
health, disease and repair of different
cells, tissues, and organs of our body.
I'd like to just take a brief
moment and thank one of our podcast
sponsors, which is InsideTracker.
InsideTracker is a personalized
nutrition platform.
They analyzes data from your blood and
DNA to help you better understand your
body and help you reach your health goals.
I've long been a believer in getting
regular blood work done for the simple
reason that blood work is the only
way that you can monitor the markers,
such as hormone markers, lipids,
metabolic factors, etc., the impact
your immediate and long-term health.
One major challenge with blood work,
however, is that most of the time it does
not come back with any information about
what to do in order to move the values
for hormones, metabolic factors, lipids,
etc., into the ranges that you want.
With InsideTracker, changing those
values becomes very straightforward
because it has a personalized
dashboard that you can use to address
the nutrition-based, behavior-based,
supplement based approaches that you
can use in order to move those values
into the ranges that are optimal for
you, your vitality and your longevity.
InsideTracker now includes a
measurement of Apolipoprotein B,
so-called ApoB in their ultimate plan.
ApoB is a key marker of cardiovascular
health and therefore there's extreme
value to knowing your ApoB levels.
If you'd like to try InsideTracker, you
can go to insidetracker.com/huberman to
get 20% off any of InsideTrackers plans.
Again, that's insidetracker.com/huberman
to get 20% off.
Let's talk about how much water, or more
generally speaking, how much fluid each
and all of us should drink each day,
and how much fluid to drink depending on
our specific activities and environment.
Now, this is perhaps the most
commonly asked question when
the topic of water comes up, how
much water do I need to drink?
The other thing that comes up is
a question, which is, can't we
just follow our natural thirst?
That is, can't we just pay
attention to when we're thirsty?
And then drink fluids?
And then that leads to the other
question, which is, does the color of
our urine provide any indication as to
whether or not we are under hydrated,
over hydrated, or hydrating correctly?
So let me answer each of
these things one at a time.
And in the backdrop, I want to highlight
the fact that there are many, many, if
not dozens, hundreds of studies pointing
to the fact that when we are dehydrated,
our brain doesn't function as well
and our body doesn't function as well.
So what I'm attempting to do in that
statement is throw a net around the
enormous number of studies that have
shown that even a slight state of
dehydration, even 2% dehydration, can
lead to a significant and meaningful
impact, that is a negative impact
on our ability to, for instance,
carry out endurance type behaviors.
So our ability to run on a
treadmill and stop at the point
where we feel we can't continue is
going to be negatively impacted.
That is we will be able to perform
less work for less period of time
when we are even slightly dehydrated.
Likewise, our strength is reduced
by even slight dehydration.
Likewise, our cognitive performance,
including memory, focus, creative
thinking, flexible thinking of different
kinds, are all significantly impaired
when we are in states of dehydration.
Now, that raises an additional question
that deserves attention, which is how
do we actually measure dehydration?
Now you hear different things like if you
pinch the skin on the top of your hand and
it takes more than three seconds to lay
down again flat, then you're dehydrated.
You hear that, you hear, okay, if you
are to press on your fingernail and see
a change in the color of the tissue,
just be below your fingernail, which
indeed does happen, and it does not go
back to its original color within one to
three seconds, then you're dehydrated.
You hear things like this if your ankles
are swollen when you're wearing socks,
you take off the socks and you can see
the imprint of the socks on your lower
limbs, that means you're dehydrated.
You hear this kind of stuff,
and you should probably be
wondering, is any of that true?
To some extent, it is true, although
it can vary quite a bit by how
old you are, whether or not  the
skin on the top of your hand tends
to be looser or not depending on
whether or not you're leaner or not.
So in other words, those
are not absolutely objective
measures of dehydration.
Now, it is true that if normally you can
pinch the skin on the top of your hand
and it returns to its normal flattened
position within about one to two or three
seconds, and it does not do that within
five or more seconds, there's a decent
probability that you're a little bit
dehydrated, that you need to ingest some
fluid, or that if you press down on your
nail and you see the depression causes a
transition from kind of a pink color to a
white color, and then you release and it
doesn't go back to its original pinkish
color within a few seconds, well then
there's a chance that you're dehydrated.
But again, these are not
perfect measures of dehydration.
You may be surprised to learn, and I
was surprised to learn that most of
the basis for these statements, like
even a 2% dehydration state, can lead
to significant reductions in cognitive
or physical performance are based on
not direct measures of hydration, but
rather on measures of reductions in water
intake, which is a different thing, right?
It's saying that ordinarily, a person
of a given body weight needs X amount
of fluid per day, and when they get even
just 2% less than that amount of fluid
than their cognitive and or physical
performance is impaired, rather than
focusing on dehydration of tissues.
Okay?
Now that might seem like a
subtle distinction, but it's
actually a meaningful distinction
when you think about it.
However, it's a meaningful
distinction that we can leverage
toward understanding how much water
or fluid we need to drink each day.
Now, there we can really point to some
solid numbers that, believe it or not,
are fairly independent of body weight.
Now, I say independent of body weight.
I'm referring to the amount of fluid
that most healthy adults need at rest.
What do I mean by at rest?
I mean when not exercising and when
not in extremely hot environments.
So I'm leaving aside you a desert
ultra marathoners or people that are
doing any kind of movement or living in
environments that are very, very hot.
Here, I'm mainly referring to people that
live most of their daily life in indoor
environments, could be air conditioned or
not air conditioned, heated or not heated.
What we're trying to arrive at here are
some numbers that can work across the
board, because of course there are an
infinite number of different conditions
that each and all of you are existing in.
So I'm not going to attempt to give you a
body weight by activity, by environment,
by humidity formula calculation.
In fact, no such calculation exists.
However, there are formulas that can
put you into very stable frameworks.
That is levels of water intake for
periods of rest when you're not exercising
and for when you are exercising, that
will ensure that you are hydrating
with the one exception being if you
are exercising or if you are living in
very, very hot conditions and you're
not heat adapted to those conditions.
So what are those numbers?
In other words, what is the
answer to the question of how
much fluid do we need each day?
And here I'm referring to fluid.
I'm not distinguishing between
water, caffeinated beverages,
soda, tea, and so on.
I'll discuss that in a moment.
We can reasonably say that for every hour
that you are awake in the first 10 hours
of your day, this is important, in the
first 10 hours of your day, you should
consume on average, 8 ounces of fluid.
Now, for those of you that are using
the metric system, not ounces, 8
ounces of fluid is approximately
236 milliliters of water.
And for those of you that exist in
the metric system and aren't used to
thinking about ounces and vice versa,
just think about a typical can of soda.
In the United States, it's 12 ounces.
In Europe, sometimes the cans of
soda are a little bit smaller, but
that's a whole discussion unto itself.
But 8 ounces of fluid, that is 236,
let's just say 240 milliliters because
we don't need to be too precise here,
of fluid on average every hour for
the first 10 hours of your day, which
translates to an average of 80 ounces
of fluid for the first 10 hours of your
day, or 2,360 milliliters of water.
In other words, approximately 2
liters of water plus a little bit more
for the first 10 hours of your day.
Now, I wanna be very clear that
this does not mean that you need to
ingest 8 ounces or 236 milliliters
of fluid on the hour, every hour
for the first 10 hours of your day.
I'm certainly not saying that.
And in fact, most people are
going to find that they're
going to ingest water in bolus.
That is, they're gonna have perhaps
16 ounces of water, 500 milliliters
of water at one portion of the day,
and then maybe a couple hours of later
that they'll drink some more water or
some more coffee or soda or some other
beverage and another portion of the day.
I do think, however, it's important for
most of us to take a step back and ask
ourselves whether or not independent
of any other activity or environmental
conditions, whether or not we are in
fact ingesting 80 ounces or basically
2.4 liters of water for that 10 hours
of the day that spans from the time
we wake up until 10 hours later.
Now, why am I setting
this 10 hour framework?
The reason I'm setting this 10 hour
framework is that it turns out that
your fluid requirements, even just
at rest, are vastly different in
the time from when you wake up until
about 10 hours later, as compared
to the later evening and nighttime.
And here I'm referring to people
that are not doing night shifts.
But if you are requesting a number of
how much fluid to drink independent
of our needs for fluid for exercise,
that's going to be 8 ounces of fluid
or 240 milliliters of fluid on average
for every hour from the time when
we wake up until 10 hours later.
That's the simple formulation that
should basically ensure that you're
getting sufficient baseline hydration
for the cells and tissues of your body.
Now, if you are engaging in exercise,
whether or not it's endurance exercise or
whether or not it's resistance training
exercise, you are going to need additional
fluids in order to maximize the effects
of that exercise and to avoid dehydration.
And there too, we have some excellent
numbers that we can look to.
Excellent, because they
arrive from research.
And this is largely peeled from
the episode that I did with Dr.
Andy Galpin, professor of
Kinesiology at Cal State Fullerton.
We did a six episode series all about
exercise, everything from strength
training, hypertrophy, endurance,
nutrition, supplementation, recovery,
everything related to exercise.
You can find all of
that at hubermanlab.com.
And one of the components of those
episodes that was discussed, but that
some of you may have not heard, is
that there is a simple formula for
how much fluid to ingest on average.
Keep in mind, this is on average when
you are exercising, and I refer to
this as the so-called Galpin equation.
The Galpin equation states that
you should take your body weight in
pounds, divide that by 30, and that
will give you the number of ounces
of fluid to ingest every 15 to 20
minutes on average while exercising.
Okay, your body weight impounds divided by
30 equals the number of ounces of fluid to
consume on average every 15 to 20 minutes.
When I say on average, what I mean
is it is not the case that you
need to stop every 15 or 20 minutes
and consume that volume of fluid.
You could sip it from moment to moment.
You could wait half an hour or
an hour and then consume a larger
bolus of fluid, a larger amount.
Although it is recommended for
performance sake that you sip
or consume beverages fairly
consistently throughout your training.
One's ability to do that is going
to depend on a number of things like
gastric emptying time, whether or
not the particular exercise you're
doing, whether or not it's running
or jumping, is compatible with
ingesting fluid on a regular basis.
Or whether or not you need to
do it at different intervals
than every 15, 20 minutes.
Maybe it's every 5 minutes,
maybe it's every half hour.
You have to adjust for you.
But if you were to take the hour of
exercise or the half hour of exercise
or the 3 hours of exercise and ask how
much fluid to ingest, it's going to be
that Galpin equation of body weight and
pounds to buy it by 30 equals the number
of ounces for every 15 or 20 minutes.
And of course, I can already
hear screaming from the back.
What about for those of us
who follow the metric system?
And there there's a simple translation
of the Galpin equation, which
is that you need approximately 2
milliliters of water per kilogram of
body weight, every 15 to 20 minutes.
Again, the Galpin equation converted
into the metric system is going to be 2
milliliters of water per kilogram of body
weight every 15 to 20 minutes on average.
I'm sure a number of you are asking
whether or not hydration prior
to exercise is also important.
It absolutely is, and if you follow
the numbers that I talked about before,
approximately 8 ounces or 240 milliliters
of fluid intake per hour in the first 10
hours of waking, that should establish a
good baseline of hydration heading into
exercise, which then prompts the next
question I often get, which is, is the
amount of water that needs to be consumed
according to the Galpin equation during
exercise on top of, or separate from that?
That is, does it replace the amount of
fluid that one needs at a basic level,
that 8 ounces or 240 milliliters?
And there the answer
sort of goes both ways.
I think if you're going to
exercise, then obviously follow
the Galpin equation in some way.
Again, you don't need to be
ultra specific about this.
These are ballpark figures that will
ensure hydration, so we've set them a
little bit higher perhaps than needed to
ensure more hydration rather than less.
But basically the short answer is if
you're exercising for about an hour,
most people are exercising for an hour
or two, probably not more than that.
Most of my workouts are
certainly the resistant training
workouts last about an hour.
Well, then you can replace the 8
ounces or the 240 milliliters of water
that's required at baseline with what
you consume according to the Galpin
equation during that bout of exercise.
A common question is if you are exercising
in a heated environment, indoor, outdoor,
or you are somebody who tends to sweat
a lot, and by the way, we can all get
better at sweating, by sweating more.
Sweat is an adaptation.
So if you sit in the sauna more,
you're gonna get better at sweating.
If you exercise more, especially if
you wear more layers, or if you do
it in hotter temperatures or more
humid temperatures, you're gonna
get better at sweating over time.
And sweating is an adaptation
that helps cool your body.
If you are sweating a lot or you're in
heat, how much fluid should you ingest?
In general, I think it's safe to say that
you may want to increase the values on
the Galpin equation by about 50 to a 100%.
So either increase by 50% or double
those numbers if you're in a very hot
environment or sweating an awful lot.
If you are sitting in the sauna, I highly
recommend consuming at least 8 ounces and
probably more like 16 ounces of fluid.
So that translates again to about 240
or about 480, let's just round up 500
milliliters of fluid for every 20 to
30 minutes that you are in a hot sauna.
And then of course,
people ask, well, how hot?
And it, okay, that starts getting
really detailed and we can't distinguish
between dry saunas and wet saunas.
And again, too many variables.
But I would double your fluid intake
for that hot environment exercise or
for that hot environment sauna sit.
Also if you are feeling dehydrated,
okay, what does feeling dehydrated mean?
That actually has a definition that
we can get into a little bit later.
But what we're really talking about here
is if you are feeling as if your throat
is dry, you are "parched", or you're very
thirsty, well then there's absolutely
no problem with ingesting more fluids.
So 16 ounces of fluid or 500
milliliters of fluid per hour
while you're feeling parched.
My read of the literature is that
thirst is a reasonable guide for
when we tend to be dehydrated.
However, it is the case that our
thirst doesn't really keep up with
our body's level of dehydration.
And we know that based on some really
nice studies that have explored the
amount of fluid intake compared to the
amount of urination, compared to the
amount of physical output compared to the
environment that one happens to be in.
And these are sort of older
studies in the realm of physiology.
But here's the basic rule of thumb
that's gonna work for most people.
If you are feeling parched, consume
fluids, ideally you consume fluids that
don't contain caffeine or other diuretics.
Diuretics being substances that cause
the release, the urination of fluid from
the body and or if you are consuming
caffeine either prior to or after bouts
of exercise or even just at work or you
work in a air conditioned or otherwise
dry, cool or hot environment, that
you try and include some sodium and
ideally sodium, potassium, magnesium,
the electrolytes in that beverage.
So it could be a little pinch
of sea salt with some lemon to
adjust the taste a little bit.
It could be an electrolyte drink,
an LMNT or some other sort, they're
a lot of different types out there.
For most people drinking pure water,
and I realize that many people do
just like the taste of pure water.
Chances are you're going to have enough
electrolytes unless you're sweating
quite a bit or you're exercising quite
a lot, and under conditions where you
are consuming very few carbohydrates,
you're going to excrete more fluid.
If you are ingesting caffeine, whether
or not it's from tea or coffee, I
highly recommend increasing your non
caffeine fluid intake about two to
one for every volume of caffeine.
So in other words, if you have a 6 ounces
or 8 ounces of coffee, you're gonna want
12 to 16 ounces of fluid, ideally fluid
with electrolytes, or a little pinch of
salt in order to offset that dehydration.
So hopefully those will provide good
rules of thumb for what people want to do
when they're just moving about their day.
Again, underscored by the fact that
even slight levels of dehydration can
really impair our cognitive and physical
performance largely by creating fatigue.
But more often than not
by creating brain fog.
You know, I get so many
questions about brain fog.
Why do I have brain fog?
There is a vast literature showing
that quality hydration, meaning
hydration that matches the demands
of humidity and output as described
in the equations that we went over a
little bit before, really can enhance
clarity of focus and overall energy.
And we'll talk about why that is, but
I'll just allude to it a little bit here.
The reason why ingesting sufficient
fluids can enhance our ability to
focus, and in fact can reduce brain
fog and can increase physical vigor
and output is not mysterious to us.
We know that there are two mechanisms
by which fluid intake triggers
elevated levels of alertness, and
it all has to do with the so-called
sympathetic arm of the autonomic nervous
system, which is a real mouthful.
But basically the sympathetic arm
of the autonomic nervous system, as
many of you've heard me talk about
before, is the aspect of your nervous
system that makes you more alert.
Has nothing to do with emotional sympathy,
has to do with a bunch of neurons in
the middle of your spinal cord called
the sympathetic chain ganglia, and
some other related neural networks
in your body, as well as regions of
your brain, like the locus coeruleus,
that release things like epinephrine
and norepinephrine and make you more
alert and in a kind of magnificent
arrangement,  or I think magnificent
arrangement, when we have fluid in our
gut and when our cells are well hydrated,
and believe it or not, when our bladder
contains fluid within it, there is an
elevation in activity of the sympathetic
nervous system by way of two pathways.
One is mechanical.
In fact, we have so-called stretch
receptors in our bladder and in our
gut, these stretch receptors have
fancy names like TRP trip channels
as they're called, or piezo, which
are these stretch sensing channels.
This is the beautiful work of many
laboratories, but in particular
David Julius and Ardem Patapoutian.
David Julius is at UC San Francisco,
Ardem is at the Scripps Institute.
They've discovered a bunch of
channels in cells that sends things
from cold to different mechanical
pressure, including expansion of
tissues so-called Mechanosensation.
And basically what it all boils down
to is that when our bladder has some
fluid in it, when our stomach has
some fluid in it, and when our cells
are sufficiently hydrated, they send
information about the mechanical
presence of that distension even.
And then here, I'm not talking
about being like overly full or, you
know, full of chock-a-block, full
of fluid or your bladder feeling,
you know, really, really full.
We'll talk about that in a moment.
But when we are sufficiently hydrated,
there's a mechanical signature of
that, which is the expansion of our
tissues because it has more fluid in it.
And there are chemical signals as
well, which is the movement of water
across those aquaporin channels is
actually understood at a biological
level by ourselves and sends information
to the areas of the brain that are
associated with so-called sympathetic
arousal and makes us more alert.
This is actually what wakes us
up in the middle of the night.
If we have consumed too much
fluid prior to sleep and we
need to urinate, we wake up.
This is a mechanism that is not adequately
developed in babies and young children.
This is why babies, young
children often will wet their bed.
And believe it or not, in both
humans and in dogs, our ability to
control urination voluntarily is
something that we actually learn.
Babies just pee in their diaper.
Dogs just pee on the floor until
their house broken or until a child
learns to hold onto their urine,
until they go to the bathroom, in the
bathroom, or particularly appropriate
location outdoors or otherwise.
The point is that hydration of the body
is signaled to the brain when we have
enough fluid in the tissues of our body,
when we've consumed enough fluid, even
if it hasn't already arrived to the cells
and tissues of our body, that is signaled
to the brain in the form of alertness.
And that alertness is what translates
to the enhanced cognitive abilities
that we have when we are well hydrated.
It's also what translates to our
enhanced physical abilities when we
are challenged with physical tasks.
So when you look out on the landscape
of all these studies that have
shown impairments in physical or
cognitive performance under conditions
of even slight dehydration, that
all makes sense because our cells
need fluid and we need water.
But it also prompts the question
of, well, does being well hydrated
actually make our brain and body
function better in the context of
physical and cognitive performance?
And indeed, the answer is yes.
Now, earlier we were talking about
these equations that you can apply.
And here again, I really want to emphasize
that these equations were not meant to
be followed down to the decimal point.
They were really meant and are meant
as crude, but sufficient guides for
you to make sure that you're getting
enough hydration depending on your
levels of activity and at rest.
If you recall when we talked about
those equations, I said, you need
about 8 ounces or 240 milliliters
of fluid per hour for the first
10 hours of your day after waking.
Now, why did I say for the first 10 hours?
Well, it turns out that the filtration
of fluids from your body, which is
accomplished of course, by your kidneys
and by way of your bladder, and the
excretion of fluid out urethra, so-called
urination, is strongly, strongly
circadian dependent, meaning the cells
of your kidney and the cells even of
your gut, in fact, all the cells of
your body, but especially the cells
of your kidney, which filter the fluid
that comes into your body, and that
makes certain hormones like vasopressin,
which is antidiuretic hormone.
All of that functioning of the kidney
is under strong regulation by so-called
circadian clock genes, circadian clock
genes are genes that are expressed
in every cell, but that in certain
cells of the body very strongly
impact whether or not that organ, in
this case, the kidney is going to be
activated, meaning functioning at a
very high level or at a reduced level.
And we can make all of this very simple
by simply stating what's contained in
this beautiful review that I'll provide
a link to if you want to learn more
called circadian rhythms in the kidney.
And basically what is known is that
for the first 10 hours after waking,
your kidney is filtering fluid within
your body at a very rapid rate.
There are a number of different cell
types that do that, but they are
basically taking that fluid, pulling
out any contaminants using hormones such
as antidiuretic hormone, vasopressin
to adjust whether or not you're gonna
hold onto fluid or release more fluid
from your body in the form of urine.
Depending on the salt concentration,
depending on how much fluid
you need, your work output, the
conditions you're in, all of that.
However, at about 10 hours after waking
your kidney really starts to reduce
its overall level of functioning.
Now that doesn't mean that your kidney
cannot filter fluid 11 or 12 or 16
hours after waking, but it becomes far
less efficient at doing so, and thank
goodness it does because you do not
want your kidney filtering fluid at
the same rate at midnight, assuming you
wake up at say, 7 or 8 or 9:00 AM that
it was filtering fluid at 10:00 AM.
In fact, we can say that if you want
to reduce your nighttime waking in
order to urinate, which is a common,
common question and concern that many
people have, how can I avoid waking up
in the middle of the night to urinate?
And there I say it's perfectly normal
to wake up once, maybe twice each night
to urinate, but if you want to reduce
the number of times that you wake up
in order to urinate across the night,
maybe even make that number zero times.
You will greatly benefit
by doing 3 things.
First of all, make sure that you're
hydrating sufficiently during the daytime
per the equations that we talked about
earlier, that will ensure that you are
not excessively thirsty in the evening
and therefore consuming a lot more fluid.
Second, and related to that first point
is that you do want to reduce your
fluid intake at night, provided you
hydrated sufficiently throughout the day.
And believe it or not, the rate at
which fluid moves from your gut and
into the cells and tissues of your body
and then from your bladder into urine
is determined not just by the volume
of fluid you ingest, but also the rate
at which you ingest that fluid and
you might be thinking, that's crazy.
That makes no sense at all, right?
If I drink a ton of fluid
slowly, doesn't it still mean
that I'm going to urinate a ton?
Yes and no.
It also stands to reason that you
might ask, if I ingest very little
fluid, but I do it very fast,
is it gonna be the case that I'm
gonna urinate it out very quickly?
Well, yes and no.
The point is that the fluid filtration
systems of your body that range from
the gut to the bladder and include the
kidney, of course, depend not just on the
volume, but on the rate of fluid that you
ingest because of those Mechanosensors
that we talked about earlier.
If you gulp down a bunch of fluids,
you are going to excrete those fluids
more quickly than if you sip them
slowly, excuse me, sip them slowly.
So here's what I recommend
throughout the day.
When you're trying to get your adequate
yield of water or other beverages,
feel free to gulp that fluid or sip it.
I'm a gulper, not a sipper, but
many of you are gonna be sippers,
not gulpers, consume fluid at the
rate that feels right to you, but
feel comfortable gulping that fluid.
However, in the evening, if you are
somebody who has challenges with
waking up excessively in the middle
of the night, reduce your fluid intake
provided you hydrate properly throughout
the day, and I suggest consuming no
more than 5, maybe 8 ounces of fluid
between the time of 10 hours after
waking and when you go to sleep.
Again, if you're very thirsty or you
under hydrate or it's very hot, feel
free to ingest more fluid please.
But most people will find that if they
reduce their fluid intake to about 5
ounces or less of fluid in that later
part of the day, after 10 hours of having
woken up and before sleep, and they sip
those beverages as opposed to gulping
them, that they will have fewer bouts
of waking up in the middle of the night
to go to the restroom and ideally zero.
Let's talk about tap water, and here
I have to take a deep breath, not a
deep gulp, but a deep breath because in
researching tap water and what's contained
in tap water in different regions, not
just in the US but around the world, I
confess the picture is a pretty scary one.
I want to be clear, I'm not somebody
who naturally orients towards
fear or conspiracy theories.
However, in researching tap water for
this episode by way of looking at the
peer reviewed research, meta-analysis
reviews, specific research articles where
specific hypotheses were tested, and in
talking with experts in toxicology and so
on, it's a pretty grim picture frankly.
When one looks at what's contained in
most tap water and whether or not the
compounds that are contained in tap water
are present in sufficient concentrations
to negatively impact our health.
And the bad news is that much, if not
all, tap water, believe it or not much if
not all, tap water contains things that
are bad for the biology of our cells.
There is a silver lining, however, and
the silver lining is that very simple
steps that are very inexpensive can
be used to adjust that tap water to
make it not just safe to drink, but
that makes it perfectly fine to drink.
So that's the good news, and
we'll get to that in a moment.
If you are somebody who is interested
in whether or not tap water contains
things like endocrine disruptors, hormone
disruptors that can negatively impact
reproductive health in males or females,
or both, there is a wonderful review,
wonderful, because it's so thorough.
Although the news isn't great, it's
very thorough, which is great, which is
entitled Endocrine Disruptors in Water and
Their Effects on the Reproductive System.
This is a review from 2020 that analyzes
water from a bunch of different sources
within the world and essentially
focuses on a few key components.
First of all, it focuses on
the concentration of minerals.
That is magnesium and
calcium within water.
Many people don't realize
this, but so-called hard
water sounds terrible, right?
But hard water is water that
contains magnesium and calcium,
which turns out to be a good thing.
Some water contains more
magnesium and calcium.
Other water contains less.
They looked at the presence of
magnesium and calcium because that
is going to impact the pH of water.
In general, the higher concentrations
of magnesium and calcium and water, the
higher the pH that is, the more alkaline
that water is, and the lower levels of
magnesium and calcium, the more acidic
or lower pH that water tends to be.
The other thing that this review addresses
is the concentration of so-called
DBPs: dog bulldog, porcupines, DBPs.
Which are disinfection
byproducts contained in water.
So obviously local governments,
the government wants your
drinking water to be clean.
They don't want contaminants in,
they don't want sewage in that water.
They don't want chemical contaminants
that are going to make people
immediately sick, so they treat water.
Water treatment plants, treat water
with disinfection products, and those
disinfection products create things
called disinfection byproducts.
And the presence of those DBPs
or disinfectant byproducts can
strongly impact the pH of water by
way of changing the concentrations
of magnesium and calcium.
Put differently, I do believe that
governments are trying to provide
people with clean water, but in doing
so, oftentimes we'll introduce things
to that water that are not good for us.
Now, it's very clear that DBPs can
cause endocrine disruption in ways that
are not good for reproductive health.
I did a very long, in fact, 4 and a half
hour episode on fertility and vitality.
That was male and female
fertility, by the way.
And vitality that again, you can find
at hubermanlab.com that talks about
all the biological processes involved
in the generation of healthy eggs and
sperm and, and creating healthy embryos,
implantation embryos, and so forth.
It's very clear that DBPs have been
shown to disrupt ovarian function,
spermatogenesis and fertility outcomes.
Even at concentrations of DBPs
that are present in drinking
water that comes from the tap.
Now, does that mean that you
shouldn't drink tap water?
Well, the answer to that is it depends.
What does it depend on?
Well, it depends on several things.
First of all, I highly recommend
to everybody go online and put
in your zip code and ask for a
water analysis of water that comes
out of the tap in that zip code.
This is something that is readily
available online, at least to my
knowledge, and unfortunately, there's no
specific one site that I can send everyone
to, to get an in-depth analysis of the
drinking water that comes out of your tap.
However, I highly recommend that you
go online and put in your zip code
or municipal area code and figure out
whether or not your water contains X
amount of DBPs or Y amount of DBPs.
Now, of course, you're gonna get a
bunch of values back, and unless you're
a toxicologist, You are probably not
gonna know what those values mean.
But what you're really looking
for is whether or not there are
high, low, or moderate levels of
fluoride in that drinking water.
Why do I say that?
Well, there are studies that show that
the concentration of fluoride in drinking
water is of particular concern for the
thyroid hormone system of the body.
Now, thyroid hormone has a lot
of different roles in brain and
body, and thyroid hormone is very
important for everything from
metabolism to levels of energy.
When thyroid levels are disrupted
or thyroid receptors are disrupted,
it can lead to depression.
When thyroid hormones are
optimized, it can lead to optimal
mood if there is such a thing.
But in other words, it helps
keep your mood elevated.
It relates to everything from sleep to
reproduction, thyroid hormones involved
in many, many things including bone
health and tissue health generally.
So essentially, every biological
process in your body is impacted by
thyroid hormone, and there's a study
that I'd like to highlight, which was
published in 2018, and the title of
the study is Impact of Drinking Water
Fluoride on Human Thyroid Hormones.
This was a case control study
so this is not an extensive
analysis of many individuals.
However, what it shows is that fluoride
negatively impacts thyroid stimulating
hormone and so-called T3 levels.
So you have thyroid hormone, T3, and T4
even in the standard concentrations that
are present of, and here's an important
number, 0.5 milligrams per liter.
Okay?
So if you can get ahold of the fluoride
concentrations in your tap water and find
out whether or not the concentrations
are at below or exceed 0.5 milligrams
per liter, what you'll find is that
even just 0.5 milligrams per liter of
water can disrupt thyroid function.
And this is going to be a particular
concern for people to have familial,
so genetically related thyroid
issues, or that are concerned with
keeping your thyroid hormone levels
healthy, which I think is everybody.
So I am telling you that you should
try and get ahold of some data about
the water that comes out of your tap
if you intend on drinking tap water.
And probably even if you don't
just know what's in your drinking
water, your local government should
provide that information and or it
should be readily available online.
And in particular, I think it's
worthwhile to address how much fluoride
is present in your drinking water.
Again, I don't want to
create a lot of scare.
I'm not trying to trigger fear here.
I do think, however, by way of reading
this review by way of reading the paper
that I just referred to a moment ago,
again, links to these are going to be
provided in the show note captions,
that there is extensive evidence that
elevated levels of fluoride in drinking
water are simply not good for us.
Now, that could open a whole discussion
of why fluoride is in our drinking
water in the first place at all.
But leaving that aside, it seems to me
that most everybody should know how much
fluoride is in their drinking water.
And ideally, everybody, yes, everybody
is filtering their drinking water.
Now, that raises the question of
how best to filter drinking water.
And that brings an answer of it
depends on a couple of things.
First of all, how healthy or
unhealthy do you know yourself to be?
Okay?
So if you're somebody who has no health
issues, you have plenty of vigor, you're
sleeping well at night, you have no
autoimmune disease, you're not aware
of any health concern, minor or major,
well then perhaps you're somebody that
doesn't want to filter your water.
I would argue that why wouldn't you
employ some very low or even zero
cost approach to filtering your water?
There are going to be other individuals
who are suffering particular ailments of
brain or body, or both, that absolutely
should be filtering their drinking water,
if they're getting their drinking the
water from their tap because it is pretty
well established now that tap water
contains a lot of these disinfectant
byproducts, as well as in most cases,
exceeding the threshold of fluoride
that we know to be healthy for us.
How should you filter your tap water?
Well, you have everything ranging
from the so-called Brita type filters.
So these are gonna be carbon type filters
or other filters that you essentially
put over a container or a compartment
where you can pour the water over it
and goes into the compartment below.
Will those work?
Are they sufficient to filter
out the disinfectant byproducts?
The general answer is yes, provided
you change the filters often enough.
However, it is not thought,
unfortunately, not thought that
they filter out sufficient fluoride.
So what I highly recommend is depending
on your budget, that you go online
and you search for at-home water
filters that can filter out fluoride.
There are a number of straightforward
and inexpensive tools to do that.
And here I don't have any relationship
to any of the water filters or
things that I'm gonna mention.
Now, I wanna be very clear about that
there's no brand code or affiliation here.
I'm simply trying to direct you to
resources that will allow you to filter
your tap water for it to be more safe for
you to consume in a way that meets your
budget with the understanding that people
have very different disposable incomes.
So the range of costs here is
going to be pretty tremendous.
I just wanna get that outta the way first.
, you know, there are water filters
that you can use repeatedly.
So these are what I'll refer
to as pitch filters that are
less than a hundred dollars.
Now keep in mind that that's a one-time
purchase except for the replacement
of the filters, which fortunately
doesn't have to be done too often.
So there are different filters.
I'll provide a link to one that
I found that is at least by my
read of the lowest possible cost.
So this is the so-called clearly filtered
water pitcher with affinity filtration.
So this is a filter that can
adequately remove fluoride, lead,
BPAs, glyphosates, hormones, and
some of the other harmful things
that are contained in most tap water.
Again, I do realize that for
some people, even an 80 US dollar
cost is going to be prohibitive.
But do realize that what you're doing
here is you're purchasing a unit that
can be used repeatedly, over and over.
The reason why it's lower cost than
some of the different filtration
approaches that I'll talk about in
a moment are that you can't really
put all the drinking water that you
would use, say for an entire week or
for an entire month in one pitcher.
You're gonna have to repeatedly pour water
into the pitcher in order to filter it.
Now, as I mentioned before, the range
on water filter costs for filters that
can adequately remove fluoride and
all the other things that you want
out of your top water is immense.
In fact, you can find you know,
whole house water filters that
are, you know, $2,000 or more.
Again, these are gonna be filters that
are gonna be in your garage or in a, a
laundry room that are going to basically
pull from the, the piping system of
your house and deliver purified water.
I technically, it's not purified, but
that's removing these contaminants  and
fluoride from all the sinks in your house.
So you could effectively drink from
any or all sinks in your house.
That's what explains the higher cost.
I think most people are probably not
going to have the disposable income
or have the opportunity to include one
of these whole house filters, although
if you do have the means and it's
important to you, you could do that.
And then there are going to be what
I would call intermediate systems.
So systems that cost somewhere
between 200 and $500.
Probably one of the more common
ones or popular ones is a
so-called Berkey filter system.
These are filter systems that, again,
remove the things that you want
removed from your tap water, and
they can do it at higher volumes.
And they're typically countertop units.
They don't require any plugin typically,
or they only require brief plugin
and electricity, and they're going to
filter out many, many liters or tens of
liters of water so that you can always
have access to that clean filtered
water time or day or night without
having to pour over into the pitcher.
So I mentioned these different options
because again, I realize that people have
different levels of disposable income.
As far as I know, there's no tablet or
simple mechanism that can be purchased
as a transportable, you know pill
that you can just simply throw in
water and remove the contaminants.
If anyone is aware of one that
can adequately remove fluoride and
other contaminants, please put in
the comment section on YouTube.
That'd be the best place.
So that I and everyone else can see
it, but hopefully the mention of the
different filtration systems that I
mentioned  we'll give you some choices
that I would hope would fall within the
range that one could potentially afford.
An important note about filtration.
Just as in our body, there are mechanisms
to signal mechanical changes and
chemical changes that occur in our
gut, in our brain, etc., elsewhere
and in general, both mechanical and
chemical changes are signaled across
the body to invoke different changes,
whether or not those are, you know,
a response of the immune system or to
make us more alert or more asleep, etc.
So too filtration capitalizes on
mechanical and chemical filtration.
What I mean by that is when you
run a fluid water or any other
fluid through a filter, those
filters are doing two things.
They are physically constraining which
molecules can go through by creating
portals, pores that allow certain size
molecules to go through and not others.
And almost always, they contain
certain chemicals themselves, right?
Those filters have been treated
with certain chemicals that
neutralize certain other chemicals.
Okay?
So you may be wondering how
when you filter water, you know,
magnesium and calcium could get
through, but fluoride doesn't.
And that's because these filters
have been very cleverly designed
in order to neutralize fluoride or
to prevent large molecules, such as
sediment and dirt, which is kind of
easy to imagine being filtered, but
also to allow certain small molecule,
like calcium, which is small-ish, or
magnesium, which is small-ish to still
pass through into our drinking water.
And this is wonderful because what
it means is that by filtering our
water, using any of the methods that
we talked about before, you're still
going to get whatever magnesium and
calcium was present in that water while
still adequately removing the fluoride
and other disinfectant byproducts.
Now, what if you can't
afford any of those options?
Okay, well here you have an
interesting zero cost option.
It's not as good as the other ones
of filtering that water, but it is an
option, and I do think it's important
to give options to people who don't have
any disposable income for the purpose
of filtering their water, which is to
draw a gallon or 5 gallons or maybe even
more, tap water out of the tap and put it
into some, some container, some vessel.
So it could be one gallon, 5
gallon, 10 gallon container.
And then to let that tap water sit for
some period of time to allow some of
the sediment to drop to the bottom.
Now you might say, well, there's no
sediment, there's nothing contained
in that tap water and it isn't
fluoride diluted in the water.
And indeed the answer to that is yes.
However, there is some evidence that
letting tap water sit out at room
temperature and outside the pipes that
deliver that water can help remove some,
not all of the contaminants in that water.
If, however you are filtering the
water using any of the methods
that I talked about a few moments
ago, you do not need to do this.
Okay?
I realize there's a whole world out there
of people who insist on putting their
water in the sun or only keeping it in
certain containers and putting it out
for a few days before they get ingested.
That to me, seems a bit extreme.
If you wanna do that, be my guest, but I
don't think most people need to do that.
However, I do believe that for people who
have zero disposable income to devote to
paying for any kind of filtration system
for their tap water, they're taking that
tap water and putting into some container
at room temperature and keeping it room
temperature for a half day or a day
or more, and then pouring off the top
two thirds of that water into another
container and consuming the water from
that second container is going to remove
some, not all of the contaminants that
one would need to be concerned about.
And here I should mention something that
I neglected to mention a few moments ago.
If you were going to do this
zero cost option and, and let the
water sit out for a bit, you would
want that water to sit uncapped.
Sorry, I should have
mentioned that before.
Uncapped, of course, trying to keep
things from falling into that water.
In fact, you could even put a a little
bit of cloth above it, so you don't
want things falling into that water,
but you want certain things to be able
to evaporate off, and you also want
some of the sediment to drop down.
And the reason why this process of letting
water sit out would work at all is because
many of the contaminants contained within
water are not present because of the
source of that water or even the treatment
of that water, but rather because of the
pipes that that water arrives to your
glass or your, the pot that you have from.
Okay?
And here again, there is an
infinite number of variables.
So some people are living in
buildings for which the pipes are
very, very old, but very, very clean.
Believe it or not, some people are
living in newer buildings and structures.
They have new pipes, but for which the
seals between those pipes contain things
that are not good for you to consume.
So by letting water sit out for a while,
you are able to remove some of the
contaminants present within the pipes of
your home and the building and even the
pipes that lead to your home or apartment.
Now, some people get really obsessed
with this old tap water thing and really
wanna find out all the details about the
pipes and what sorts of, you know, hard
metals and how much magnesium and how
much calcium are present in their water.
There are ways that you can test your
drinking water for those sorts of things.
Most people, I realize, including
myself, are simply not going to do that.
If you want to know what I do, I tend
to drink water that is filtered through
one of these lower cost filters.
Or if I'm going to be consuming a lot
of fluid, I will drink certain kinds
of fluid that later I'll tell you, I've
been doing an experiment for sake of this
episode looking at so-called molecular
hydrogen water, which sounds very fancy
and esoteric and almost a little wacky.
But it turns out has largely to do
with the amount of magnesium and
calcium and the pH of that water.
So if you are somebody who has a very
low budget or simply just wants to
spend a very small amount of money and
try and still drink tap water, there
is absolutely a way to do that safely.
But it does require a few of these steps.
So, on the topic of magnesium and
calcium, this relates, as I mentioned
earlier, to the "hardness" of water.
So what of the hardness of water, you
know, is it better to have more magnesium
and calcium in your water or less?
Some people don't like
the taste of hard water.
They prefer the taste of water
that has less magnesium in calcium.
However, there I would encourage
you to take a step back and
consider some of the literature.
In fact I'll mention a paper in particular
now, published in 2019, which describes
the quote, regulations for calcium,
magnesium, or hardness in drinking water
in the European Union member states.
Turns out in Europe, they do very
detailed  water analysis and that's
present in a number of really high
quality scientific publications.
This was a paper published in regulatory
toxicology and pharmacology, and they
cite a number of different references
in the introduction that, for instance,
in here I'm quoting statistically
significant inverse association between
magnesium and cardiovascular mortality.
Now, again, that's a, an association,
this is not causal, but higher magnesium
in water, lower cardiovascular mortality.
They go on to say the highest exposure
category, which are people consuming
drinking water with magnesium contents
of 8.3 to 19.4 milligrams per liter.
Again, when you get your water analysis,
you can compare against some of these
values was significantly associated with
decreased likelihood of cardiovascular
mortality by 25% compared with
people consuming magnesium content
of 2.5 to 8.2 milligrams per liter.
Okay, so what this basically shows,
and, and by the way, the reference
to that I'll also provide a link
to, in the show note caption.
What this basically states is that
higher magnesium containing water,
and it turns out higher magnesium and
calcium  containing water, so-called
harder water may not taste as good to
you, but turns out to be better for you.
Now, whether or not it can prevent
you from getting cardiovascular
disease, I don't know.
In fact, I would probably just
state no, it probably won't prevent
you from cardiovascular disease.
You still need to do all the other
things that are important for
avoiding cardiovascular disease
and cerebral vascular disease.
For that and what to do in order
to avoid cardiovascular disease.
I strongly encourage you to
listen to the episode with Dr.
Peter Attia, that's coming out in a
few weeks that gets deep into that
topic and the actionable items for
avoiding cardiovascular disease.
But basically, as this study quotes,
there is a growing consensus among
epidemiologists and epidemiological
evidence along with clinical and
nutritional evidence that's strong
enough to suggest that new guidance
should be issued in terms of how these
different sources of tap water should
enhance, not deplete the amount of
magnesium and calcium in that water.
Now, this ought to raise a very
important question in all of your
minds, which is why is it that
magnesium and calcium concentrations
are relevant to cardiovascular disease?
Is it something about what magnesium does
in cells or what calcium does in cells?
Are we all magnesium
and calcium deficient?
Well, it turns out that's not the case.
The major effect by which magnesium and
calcium in water are likely to impact
things like blood pressure, cardiovascular
disease, and other aspects of cellular
function turn out to be somewhat cryptic.
But we can make that cryptic aspect
very clear by saying that when we
have more magnesium in particular,
but also calcium present in our water,
so-called hard water, you increase
the amount of hydrogen in that water.
It becomes what we call hydrogen rich
and the pH of that water is increased.
Now again, this does not mean that we are
trying to change the pH of the cells of
our body in any kind of meaningful way.
In fact, we don't want to do that.
We want the pH of the cells of our
body to stay in particular ranges as
I mentioned earlier, but having more
magnesium and more calcium in our water
that is increasing the hardness of our
water changes the pH of that water.
And it turns out that the elevated pH
of water, that is pH of water that tends
to be somewhere between high sevens.
So we could say 7.9 up to even 9 or 9.2
is going to be more readily absorbed and
is going to more favorably impact the
function of our cells than lower pH water.
Again, I wanna restate this because
I'm a little bit concerned that
maybe a clip of this is gonna be
taken and, and send elsewhere.
And someone will get the impression
that I'm saying that we actually want
to drink high pH water, that we all
need to buy expensive high pH water.
Turns out that's not the case.
If you are consuming tap water from a
location where levels of a magnesium are
sufficiently high in that tap water again,
where the level of magnesium is 8.3 to
19.4 milligrams per liter of water, that
is, if the water coming out of your tap
is hard enough, well then chances are you
don't need to enhance the pH of that water
or change its magnesium concentration.
If, however, the water that you're
drinking from the tap filtered or
not, I would hope filtered contains
less than 8.3 milligrams per liter of
magnesium, well then chances are the
pH of that water is going to be low
enough that it's not going to be lending
itself to some of the favorable health
components that higher pH water can.
Notice, I did not say that lower pH
aka more acidic water is bad for you.
I didn't say that.
I said that higher pH
water can be good for you.
So let's talk about how and why
higher pH water can be good for you.
And some of the best, and in fact,
very inexpensive sources of higher
pH magnesium enhanced or simply
tap water that contains sufficient
magnesium can be used and accessed.
Many of you are probably wondering whether
or not you can simply boil your tap water
and thereby decontaminate the tap water.
There I want to caution you,
it turns out that some of the
contaminants present in water are
actually made worse by heating water.
And again, I don't want to open up you
know, a whole catalog of different fears.
I, like all of you, I presume, use
water to cook pasta, rice, because I'm
an omnivore, I do consume those things.
I confess if I make Yerba Matte or any
kind of tea or coffee, I tend to use
a higher quality water source than tap
water, even if that tap water is filtered,
because I like the taste far more if I use
a really good source of water, and again,
because I'm not consuming those beverages
in enormous volumes, that becomes a,
a relatively inexpensive endeavor.
But I would caution people against
using boiling or heating of water
as the only method to decontaminate
their tap water and instead to
also rely on some of the filtration
systems that I talked about before.
And as long as we're talking about
the temperature of water, there is
sort of an ongoing debate online.
It's not a huge debate, but a number
of people engaged in this debate as
to whether or not drinking really
cold water or room temperature water
is better for you or worse for you.
This is a tough one to resolve.
It turns out that if water is very, very
cold, that is if you drink it and you can
feel that cold water making its way down
to your gut and you can actually feel it
as cold within your gut, that's sort of a,
a you know, back of the envelope, , or I
should say direct within the gut measure
of cold versus body temperature water,
that it is going to be slower to absorb.
That is you're gonna feel it sloshing
around in your stomach for a bit
longer than if you were to consume
water that is slightly warmer.
Now, that is not to say that
you should ingest warm water
or room temperature water.
However, many people find that when
they drink very cold water or ice water,
that indeed it can alter the kind of
sensation of the lining of their stomach
in ways that at least to them feel
like it's altering their digestion.
And that makes sense.
The cells that line the gut
are very temperature sensitive.
You want this so for a number of
reasons, including not consuming
food that is excessively hot
or cold or damaging your gut.
But in general, most people know
the temperature of fluid that
they want to ingest and ingest
that temperature of fluid.
So most people, for instance, on a
cold day, want a warmer or hot fluid.
Does that mean that you're not going
to absorb that warmer hot fluid?
No, of course it doesn't.
You're going to absorb that
fluid one way or the other.
So drink fluids at the temperatures
that are to your liking in that moment.
In other words, what you desire in
that moment and don't worry so much
about trying to avoid cold beverages
or trying to make sure that you're
always consuming room temperature
water as opposed to cold water.
So now with your understanding of
hard water, soft water, magnesium, the
relationship between magnesium, calcium,
and the pH of water, and remember our
earlier conversation where we talked
about how higher pH water is actually
going to move out of the gut and into
the body a bit more readily, and across
those aquaporin channels more readily
than lower pH, more acidic water.
Well, that raises the question of
whether or not all these different forms
of water that are out there, reverse
osmosis water, distilled water, double
distilled water deuterium-depleted
water, alkaline water, as it's often
called, whether or not any or all of
that has meaningful health outcomes.
Here we can address some of
those items pretty quickly.
For instance, distilled water and
double distilled water is essentially
distilled of that is it has magnesium
and calcium removed from it.
So my recommendation would be
to not drink distilled water.
There may be specific circumstances where
somebody has very high levels of blood
magnesium or calcium or calcium stores
within the body that would necessitate
them drinking only distilled water.
But that seems like a very
isolated kind of niche case.
So in general, consuming distilled
water is just simply not necessary.
Now in terms of reverse osmosis
water, what is reverse osmosis water?
Reverse osmosis water is water that
has been passed repeatedly through a
series of filters that are designed
to remove the kinds of contaminants
we were talking about earlier.
So some of the basic contaminants like
disinfectant byproducts, fluoride, and
some other large and small molecules
that leaves the water ideally still
containing magnesium and calcium.
Although there's some evidence that
reverse osmosis water can deprive water
of some of the magnesium and calcium.
So if you are going to use reverse
osmosis filters and drink reverse
osmosis water, you want to make
sure that you're still getting the
magnesium concentrations present in
that water that we talked about earlier.
But in general, reverse osmosis water
is considered safe, but, and for many
people, this is gonna be an important
but but very expensive to access.
The reverse osmosis filters require
a lot of changing of the filters.
Purchasing reverse osmosis water in
its stable form within containers,
these are typically glass containers,
is going to be pretty expensive
and prohibitive for most people.
That said, there are a number of
people out there that really like
the taste of reverse osmosis water.
They report it as feeling more smooth.
They think of reverse osmosis
water as "giving them energy".
To be quite honest, there's no direct
studies of the subjective sensation
of water in the mouth and in the
gut, and its relative health effects.
Again, the smoothness of water
as one drinks it and goes down.
The gut really has no direct relationship
to the "hardness or softness" of water.
I know that's going to
shock a number of you.
You probably think, well, hard
water is gonna be hard to drink, and
it turns out that's not the case.
In fact, many people find that with
elevated levels of magnesium and
calcium and water, it actually tastes
smoother or softer in their mouth.
So hard water tastes smooth or soft.
I know it's all very counterintuitive,
but I think it's important to point this
out because a number of times you'll
hear or read about filtering water so
that it tastes smoother and better.
And oftentimes that's happening
because the "hardness" of water that
is the concentrations of magnesium
and calcium are actually increasing.
So if you're somebody who's curious about
reverse osmosis water and you can afford
the filters or the reverse osmosis water
already pre-filtered please be my guest.
You know, drink it.
I'm certainly not trying to prevent
anyone from drinking it, but there's
no peer reviewed evidence that I am
aware of that conclusively shows that
drinking reverse osmosis water is far
better for us than drinking other types
of water, provided the other types
of water are adequately filtered of
fluoride and the sorts of disinfectant
byproducts that we talked about earlier.
So what about hydrogen water?
You may have heard of this,
or hydrogen enriched water or
electrolyzed reduced water as a way
to access hydrogen enriched water.
All this might sound pretty
crazy to some of you.
Now, fortunately, for sake of
today's discussion, we can take a
number of the different categories
of, let's call it unique categories
of water that have been described,
including deuterium-depleted water.
And by the way, deuterium is
something that relates to the
presence of hydrogen ions in water.
And put very simply, water that is
extracted from sources that are closer
to sea level tend to have more deuterium
in them than water that is extracted
from sources further from sea level.
So up in the mountains, for instance, and
from springs further away from oceans.
As you get closer to sea level, the
sources water separate from seawater
tend to have more deuterium, which
relates to the enrichment or lack
of hydrogen within that water or
free hydrogen within that water.
I warned you this was all gonna sound
pretty niche and that we were gonna get
a little bit into the chemistry, but now
I'm gonna make it all very simple for
you, at least for the non aficionado.
Electrolyzed reduced water, which is
a method of using electricity to alter
the confirmation of the water molecules
and their rates of movement as well,
as well as so-called hydrogen rich
water, or hydrogen enriched water or
deuterium-depleted water, all have the
property of having higher levels of
pH than other forms of water, such as
distilled water, reverse osmosis water,
and generally higher pH than the kind
of water that comes out of your tap.
Unless you live in a region where
your tap water has very high levels of
magnesium in it, which does occur in
certain regions of the world, but is not
that common more typically, the water
that comes out of your tap does not
have enough magnesium, meaning not as
much magnesium in it as you would like.
And this, I believe, explains in a
fairly straightforward way why there is
such an appeal of these pH enhanced or
alkaline waters or electrolyzed reduced
water or deuterium-depleted water.
There are a couple of reasons, but
first of all, anytime someone is
consuming a specialized form of water,
chances are it's going to be filtered
of the disinfectant byproducts,
fluoride, and the other things that
you really don't want in water.
So already the water is going
to be cleaner than would
be coming out of the tap.
So that's going to indirectly explain
a number of the so-called health
benefits, both subjective and perhaps
even objective as we'll talk about
that can result from consuming these
other let's say more esoteric forms of
water, at least not of simple tap water.
However, if you look at hydrogen or
hydrogen enriched water, you really need
to take a step back and ask, what is that?
You know, what are we
really talking about?
Because it turns out that you can create
hydrogen enriched water by putting tablets
of magnesium itself, small amounts of
magnesium dissolving those in water.
It will give off a kind
of gaseous solution.
You'll see a bunch of bubbling in there.
You certainly want to dilute that
tablet and then consume the water.
And yes, it's true what you've heard about
and read from these commercial sources.
You do want to consume that water within
about, you know, five to 15 minutes
after that tablet completes dissolving.
Now, why would you do this?
And I should say that I have now started
doing this not because I necessarily think
that it's so necessary or so beneficial.
I'll talk about my experience in a moment.
I did it in anticipation of this
episode because I was researching
water and hydrogen enrich water
and all these alkaline waters.
And what became very clear to me
based on reading a fantastic two-part
review, it's a very extensive review
entitled, or at least the first part
is entitled: Electrolyzed Reduced Water
Molecular Hydrogen is the Exclusive Agent
Responsible for the Therapeutic Effects.
And then there's a second
part to this review.
This is how extensive it is, entitled:
Electrolyzed Reduced Water number
two, safety Concerns and Effectiveness
as a source of Hydrogen Water.
What this review, which we've linked
to in the show notes, points to is that
all of the health benefits of these
different forms of water that you hear
about out there, deuterium-depleted,
hydrogen enrich, etc., all seem
to boil down, no pun intended, no
boiling included, I should say, to the
elevation in hydrogen that translates
into, and here's the really meaningful
change, the elevation in pH that
occurs when you hydrogen enrich water.
Now, there are not a lot of
clinical studies looking at hydrogen
enriched water, but there are
starting to be more than a few.
And one that I'd like to point out
and that we'll link to, was published
fairly recently, which is entitled
Hydrogen-rich water reduces inflammatory
responses and prevents apoptosis.
Apoptosis is a naturally occurring cell
death during development and is generally
used to describe cell death of the body.
Sometimes this can be good cell
death, by the way, removing
cells that need to be removed.
Again, the title of the paper is:
Hydrogen-Rich water reduces inflammatory
responses and prevents apoptosis of
peripheral blood cells in healthy Adults.
A randomized double
blind controlled trial.
Now this paper looked at the effects of
drinking 1.5 liters per day of hydrogen
enriched water for a period of four weeks.
They did find significant positive
benefits of reduced inflammation, and
they found these changes by way of
analyzing things like interleukin 6
and some of the other interleukins,
which are markers of inflammation.
They controlled very nicely for the
fact that people were still consuming
other forms of water and liquid and
coffee, etc., although they made
sure that they weren't consuming
too much coffee and soda in addition
to this hydrogen enriched water.
But what this paper shows is that
indeed, increasing the free hydrogen
in water can improve certain
health metrics in these cells.
And this is in keeping with some of the
subjective reports that people have stated
out there, and that I myself experience,
I have to say that by drinking hydrogen
rich water, which I'll tell you how to
do fairly inexpensively in a moment,
you do get the subjective experience of
having more energy, of "feeling better".
Now, keep in mind, of course, the placebo
effect is a very real and powerful
effect, so it could just be placebo,
although in this paper they did of
course include a placebo group, so people
didn't know if they were getting hydrogen
rich water or non hydrogen rich water.
I should also mention that the
improvements in health metrics that they
observed in this study were only observed
for individuals older than 30 years old.
Why that is, I don't know, the conclusions
these authors came to in terms of how
these individuals older than 30 achieved
lower levels, or I should say reduced
levels of inflammation and improved
markers of other aspects of biological
function is that the hydrogen water
improved the biological antioxidant
potential of certain cell types.
And again, the cell types that they
mainly focus on were these peripheral
blood cells in this particular study.
Now, how could this be?
Why would this be?
Well, this goes back to our earlier
discussion about reduction in
reactive oxygen species, so-called
ROSs, and reductions in free
radicals that can damage cells.
So if all of this is sounding very
convoluted, I can understand why.
However, what I like about this
study and the two reviews that
I mentioned a moment ago is that
these studies don't really say that
hydrogen-rich water is what's essential.
What these studies really point to is
that the changes in pH of water that
enhancing the hydrogen in water can
create, is what leads to the enhanced
either absorption and or ability of
cells to utilize that higher pH water.
Again, not by changing the pH of the body
or of cells, but simply because higher pH
water or we could perhaps more accurately
state less acidic water, that is harder
water that contains more magnesium and
calcium, seems to be more readily used
by the cells of the body and therefore
it's very likely that the individuals
in this study were achieving  higher
or more efficient levels of hydration.
Okay, so if any of this is
confusing, let me be very clear.
I do not believe that we all need to
drink deuterium-depleted water or that
we all need to drink electrolyzed reduced
water, nor do I necessarily believe that
we all need to drink hydrogen rich water.
However, it's very clear to me that
all these different forms of water are
better absorbed and therefore lead to
better and more efficient hydration, and
therefore can reduce inflammation, blood
pressure, and improve a number of other
health metrics because of the elevated pH
that all of these different purification
or water treatment methods achieve.
And that elevated pH, again, is not
changing the pH of the cells and
tissues and organs of your body.
You actually don't want that, rather that
elevated pH is simply making the water
less acidic than it would be otherwise.
So the simple takeaway is this, if
your tap water contains sufficient
magnesium per the values that we
talked about earlier, I don't think
you need to hydrogen enrich your water.
I do however, suggest that you at least
analyze your water or look at some of
the professional analysis of water that
you can achieve online and filter out
disinfectant byproducts and fluorides,
etc., from that magnesium, or I should say
sufficiently magnesium containing water.
Okay?
Put simply, if your tap water has
enough magnesium, filter it, but drink
it and I think you're doing just fine.
If, however, the levels of magnesium in
your tap water are not above that value
that we talked about earlier in that
case, I do think, and I can completely
understand why enriching the amount of
hydrogen in that water can make that
water not only more palatable, right?
Give you the sensation that it's
softer or smoother or more enjoyable to
drink than more acidic water would be.
But also that that water is going
to be far more effective in being
absorbed and hydrating in the cells and
tissues of your body, which turns out
to be very important for an enormous
range, perhaps every biological
function within your brain and body.
So how can you hydrogen enrich your water?
That actually can be done
fairly inexpensively.
I've been doing that as I mentioned
earlier, as part of an experiment in
preparation for this episode, because
it turns out that the water that comes
out of my tap has very little magnesium
in it and very little calcium as well.
The way to create hydrogen-rich water
is you can simply purchase molecular
hydrogen tablets, which in reality are
just magnesium tablets that dissolve in
water and create a free hydrogen that can
interact with the other water molecules.
Now, the chemistry behind it has
been substantiated, and I'll provide
a link in the show note captions to
a paper that gets into some fairly
extensive detail about the way that
having an additional hydrogen in your
water can adjust the flow of electrons
and the adjustment of free radicals.
But keep in mind, again, this is all
through increases in the pH of your water,
and please keep in mind that you can't
simply take any other or any old magnesium
tablet or capsule and put it into water.
The configuration of the magnesium
in these capsules and tablets is such
that it allows a rapid dissolving
of the tablet and the activation
of the free hydrogen that can
interact with the water molecules.
Again, there are only a few
scientific studies exploring
the real biological effects of
these activated hydrogen waters.
The dissolvable tablets are the far
less expensive way to go than purchasing
pre-packaged and sealed hydrogen water.
In fact, I don't recommend those brands
because they are quite expensive and
it's not clear how stable the activated
or free hydrogen is in those waters.
In any case, this is certainly not
something that everyone needs to do.
I mention it because I have had
a good experience with it myself.
I also will mention again that I
have no business or affiliation
to any of these products.
I'll provide a link to a few of them
in the show note captions for those
of you that want to experiment.
And indeed, that's why I'm telling
you this, for those of you that want
to experiment with raising the pH of
your water without having to purchase
what is ordinarily quite expensive,
higher pH water, you can do this with
these dissolvable magnesium tablet.
My experience with them
has been quite good.
In fact, I plan to continue to
use them once or twice a day.
This is not the sort of thing
that you need to do in all
the water that you drink.
I want to repeat, even if you go down
this path and you find that you really
like the activated hydrogen tablet
approach, it is not the case that you
want to put these in all of your water,
and you certainly don't want to put
them in carbonated waters of any kind.
That will lead to a lot of gastric
discomfort, nor do you want to put
them into hot liquids of any kind.
So again, this is the sort of thing
that you do once or twice, maybe three
times a day, and you can find out for
yourself and sort of measure subjectively
whether or not you like the experience
and whether or not you "feel better".
Now, earlier in the episode we
were discussing structured water
or this fourth phase of water.
I know a number of people out there are
curious as to whether or not ingesting
structured water is somehow better for
us than ingesting non-structured water.
All I can say about this is that it is
a very controversial thing to suggest
that structured water is somehow
more biologically effective or better
for us than non-structured water.
There are a number of different ways
that one can create structured water.
They involve some pretty extensive and
expensive at-home systems ranging anywhere
from a couple of hundred dollars to
a couple of thousand dollars or more.
To be quite direct, when one goes into
the peer reviewed scientific literature,
one will not find that is there is
essentially no real evidence that
ingesting structured water leads to any
specific desired biological outcomes.
Now, as I say that, I'm sure there
are people out there who have still
had tremendous experiences ingesting
structured water, whether or not that's
due to a placebo effect or a real effect
of ingesting structured water isn't clear.
Just to give you a sense of what my
stance is on things like structured
water, I think that they are interesting
and intriguing, but as a scientist, in
the absence of any quality peer review
data at present, I can't really suggest
that people go out and start ingesting
structured water nor that they adhere
to the claims that structured water
is going to be really, really good for
them compared to other forms of water.
That said, I do think that there's
an interesting and open space for
further exploration of the biological
effects of structured water given the
fact that structured water does exist.
I don't think anyone debates that,
and the fact that the different
structures of water in this fourth
phase of water as we're calling it,
has been shown to interface with solids
and other aspects of liquids and can
do so within organelles of cells.
So different components of
cells that control different
functions, including mitochondria.
I think there's a potential there,
whether or not there's a promise
there, is a another question entirely.
So I don't wanna shut the
door on structured water.
I think this is an open question
that I hope there will be more
data to answer those questions
in the not too distant future.
And meanwhile, if any of you are aware
of good clinical studies exploring
the biological effects of structured
water in either animal models or
humans, please put those references
in the comments on YouTube because I'm
very curious as to how this area of
biological effects of structured water
is evolving and continues to evolve.
So today we discussed water, and
admittedly we went into a lot of
detail about the physics and chemistry
of water in its various forms.
And we talked about hydration because
I think that's the main reason
why many of you are interested
in or concerned about water.
We also talked about contaminants
and tap water, which unfortunately
do exist and are very prominent in
essentially all regions of the world.
So please do get some information
about what's coming out of your tap.
I also wanna throw in one other piece of
information that's really critical that
I learned about when researching this
episode, which is the quality of water
that comes out of your tap is not just
dictated by the source that it comes
from external to your home or apartment,
your pipes are also important, and that
filter, or that little mesh that sits at
the faucet head is also very important.
Most people don't pay attention to that,
but it turns out that a lot of debris
and contaminants can be derived from
that little filter that most people just
simply aren't cleaning often enough.
So here, I'm not trying to tell you
that the metal or the plastic that
that filter is made of is a problem.
More often than not, contaminants are
showing up in water because people aren't
cleaning those filters often enough.
And in fact, prior to researching
this episode, I didn't ever
think to clean that filter.
I looked underneath my faucet and while
that filter didn't look particularly
filled with debris, I did find that when
I took it off and I looked at the other
sign, there was quite a lot of debris.
So if you are going to consume tap
water, you definitely want to consider
the source, the pipes in your building
or apartment, the ones that lead right
up to your glass or jug that you would
put that water into, and also that
mesh that that water passes through
as it goes into that glass or jug.
We also talked about
how much water to drink.
I hope that we finally
resolve that question.
For those of you that have
been wondering about that.
The Galpin equation is a wonderful
approach to how much water
to consume during exercise.
And by providing these other formulas
of about 8 ounces or 240 milliliters
of water per hour for the 10 hours
from waking until post waking on
average, remember it's averages.
You don't have to consume them every hour
on the hour, and no need to be neurotic.
Hopefully you can achieve better
levels of hydration, which we know can
lead to reductions in blood pressure
improvements in appetite, mood, and focus.
And I really think that it's the
improvements in cognitive focus and
physical ability, both endurance strength
and other forms of kind of readiness
in the body, readiness to perform
work in the body that really are best
supported by the hydration literature.
And then of course, we went through the
different forms of water that you hear
about out there and addressed which ones
are going to be beneficial or not and
perhaps more importantly, why any of
them  would be beneficial thinking about
that from the perspective of biologists
and the chemistry of water, and I do
hope that by arriving at this point in
the episode, now that you have a much
better understanding of the chemistry
and physics of water and the way that
water can powerfully impact your biology.
If you're learning from and or
enjoying this podcast, please
subscribe to our YouTube channel.
That's a terrific zero
cost way to support us.
In addition, please subscribe to the
podcast on both Apple and Spotify.
And on both Apple and Spotify, you can
also leave us up to a five star review.
If you have questions for us or
comments about the podcast or topics
you'd like me to cover, or guest
that you'd like me to include on the
Huberman Lab podcast, please put those
in the comments section on YouTube.
I do read all the comments.
In addition, please check out the
sponsors mentioned at the beginning
and throughout today's episode.
That's the best way to
support this podcast.
On various episodes of the Huberman
Lab podcast, we discuss supplements.
While supplements aren't necessary
for everybody, many people derive
tremendous benefit from them for
things like improving sleep, supporting
hormones, improving focus, and so on.
The Huberman Lab Podcast is proud to have
partnered with Momentous supplements.
We've done that for several reasons.
First of all, Momentous supplements are
the very highest quality and are used with
various sports teams in various studies
through the Department of Defense and
so on, and Momentous supplements tend
to be in single ingredient formulations.
Single ingredient formulations are
absolutely essential if you are going
to develop the most cost effective
and biologically effective supplement
regimen for you, because simply
put, they allow you to adjust the
dosage of individual ingredients to
alternate days that you take different
ingredients to cycle them and so forth.
In addition, Momentous supplements
are available internationally, which
many other supplements are not.
If you'd like to see the supplements
discussed on the Huberman Lab podcast,
you can go to Live Momentous, spelled
O-U-S livemomentous.com/huberman.
If you're not already following
me on social media, it's
Huberman Lab on Instagram,
Twitter, Facebook, and LinkedIn.
And at all of those places, I cover
science and science-based tools, some
of which overlap with the contents
of the Huberman Lab podcast, but much
of which is distinct from the content
covered on the Huberman Lab podcast.
Again, it's Huberman Lab on
all social media platforms.
If you haven't already subscribed
to the Huberman Lab podcast, Neural
Network Newsletter, it's a monthly
newsletter that includes free toolkits
for things like toolkit for sleep, how
to enhance the quality and duration of
your sleep, toolkit for focus, toolkit
for neuroplasticity, toolkit for
deliberate cold exposure, heat exposure,
and summaries of podcast episodes.
All of those toolkits can be
found by going to hubermanlab.com.
Go to the menu, scroll down to
newsletter, and simply give us your email.
We do not share your email with
anybody, and again, the newsletters
and toolkits are completely zero
cost, and you'll also find some
PDF examples of previous toolkits.
Again, that's hubermanlab.com.
Thank you once again for joining me
for today's discussion all about the
science, including the chemistry,
physics, and biology of water,
and how your body utilizes water.
And last but certainly not least,
thank you for your interest in science.
[MUSIC PLAYING]